[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue en direct sur
public sénat édition spéciale à faire
benalla avec la reprise des auditions de
la commission denquête les sénateurs
entendent eux patrick strzoda directeur
de cabinet des manuels macron selon lui
alexandre benalla a utilisé une
vingtaine de fois ces passeports
diplomatiques depuis son licenciement
une information importante sur laquelle
nous allons revenir tout au long de
cette édition spéciale mais tout de
suite place au direct on écoute patrick
strzoda nous avons été informés les
déplacements de monsieur bénin pas des
interrogations de la presse
aux environs de du 20 décembre du 20
décembre 2018
quelques jours avant que le président de
la république se rende au tchad
nous avons été interrogés plusieurs
questions est ce que vous allez
connaissance que monsieur benalla se
vendant les plusieurs pays africains et
qu'il utiliserait son passeport
diplomatique c'est comme ça que nous
l'avons pas d'autre moyen de savoir
écouter monsieur le directeur jeu très
très franchement un e
je réagissais tout à l'heure et j'assume
aussi à mon interrogation s'emparer d'un
très difficile d'imaginer que monsieur
benalla ait pu être reçus par un chef
d'état qui devait recevoir le président
de la république quelques jours après
sans que d'aucune manière
ni l'ambassade ni les services de
renseignement venez pu vous fournir
cette information à l'elysée maintenant
j'accepte tout je prends acte vraiment
de ce que vous dites mais il faut à ma
place ça m'apparaît quand même étrange
voilà quelqu'un qui est licencié pour
faute
c'est quand même une faute grave ce qui
s'est passé le 1er mai c'est quand même
pas bénin bon sur lequel les feux de
l'actualité sont ce qu'ils sont qui est
reçu par un chef d'état
peu de jours avant que le président de
la république soit reçue par le même
chef d'état je prends acte du fait que
l'elysée n'était pas au courant puisque
vous le dites mais ça m'a paru un peu
étrange permettez-moi de le dire
simplement un mais je le dis sincèrement
et je suis très sincère je pense qu'il
ya quand même des sam evans ça me paraît
bizarre que personne à l'ambassade de
france au tchad n'ai eu connaissance de
cette audience accordée par le chef
d'état du tchad
voilà chers collègues je perdrais
simplement je fais peut-être tort mais
je t'en fais ça non mais j'essaie de
voir que les l'intérieur des élections
directeur issia mission de la commission
directeur set je devrais je voudrais
simplement dans dans mon rôle de
président vous dire que le temps avance
cette audition est extrêmement
intéressante et je mesure
monsieur le directeur
l'indignation contenu que vous avez
devant un certain nombre de
constatations que vous avez fait et je
ressens la sincérité de votre propos à
cet égard nous nous efforçons sans vous
mettre en cause de comprendre ce qui se
passe
cette affaire a pris des proportions
qu'aucun d'entre nous ne pouvait
imaginer nous essayons de faire notre
travail en étant fidèle à notre mandat
et aux règles de la séparation des
pouvoirs
un certain nombre de questions vous ont
été posées vous avez apporté des
réponses je dois dire en mettant sur la
table des informations très importantes
et je crois que il faut tout à fait le
reconnaître et nous vous en remercions
alors il faut qu'on fasse attention de
ne pas prolonger cette audition au delà
du nécessaire compte tenu notamment du
fait que nous additionnons ensuite deux
membres du gouvernement mais nous avons
encore beaucoup de questions à vous
poser il fait d'abord si monsieur sur le
père mère redonner la parole à madame
jourdain
monsieur sur pour à la reprendre s'ils
le souhaitent mais surtout mes chers
collègues
vous êtes nombreux à avoir demandé la
parole et je ne voudrais pas qu'il y ait
de frustration il va falloir qu'on
s'organise bien pour que chacun d'entre
vous et j'entends est évidemment le
désagrément qui peut y avoir de devoir
contenir votre temps de parole alors que
les rapporteurs eux-mêmes mais vu les
auront désignés en confiance pour cela
ont pu s'exprimer très largement mais il
faudra qu'on arrive malgré tout même si
c'est difficile a essayé de contenir un
petit peu d'autant plus que beaucoup de
questions très approfondies ont déjà été
posés le temps consacré à la deuxième
partie de notre audition c'est à dire
celle au cours de laquelle vous allez
pouvoir poser vos questions à nos jours
d'un merci monsieur le président
monsieur le directeur vous avez indiqué
tout à l'heure que les passeports de
service ou le solliciter leur
invalidation
dès le 31 juillet pourquoi la même
procédure ne t'elle pas été suivies pas
pour les places port diplomatique et n'y
avait-il pas un moyen de prévenir par
exemple de donner instruction à la
police de l'air et des frontières pour
qu'ils ne puissent pas être utilisés
quelle est la procédure finalement qui a
été suivie pour les pour les passeports
diplomatiques par rapport à celles qui
étaient sur les passeports de service
je comprends parfaitement que vous posez
cette question mais vous avez devant
vous madame le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république il n'est pas
dans les compétences de voir comment
sont gérées les passeports entre tel ou
tel service permettait manquant même de
vous rappeler que le directeur de
cabinet du président république est
chargée essentiellement de gérer
l'agenda du président république
d'organiser ses déplacements de lui
préparer des dossiers sur les luttes
contre le terrorisme la sécurité des
flux migratoires des dossiers relatifs
au conseil des ministres de recevoir
beaucoup de responsables qui me manque
de recevoir pour voir quelles sont leurs
préoccupations responsables politiques
associatifs syndicaux de rédiger des
notes d'encadrer une équipe
et puis également de piloter au côté du
secrétaire général le projet de
réorganisation de l'elysée
tout ceci se fait au cours d'une journée
de travail qui commence à 7h15 le matin
qui se termine rarement avant minuit
donc vous comprendrez que les
tribulations de monsieur benalla ne sont
pas ma priorité et qu'il n'est pas dans
mes radars depuis le 1er août
ceci dit j'assume mes responsabilités et
avec les services qui sont son autorité
je viens devant vous pour vous dire
voilà ce qui a été fait lorsqu'on a
découvert tel ou tel comportement fautif
de la part de l'intéressé
alors pourquoi est ce que les passeports
n'ont pas été contrôlés à tel ou tel
frontière très très franchement madame
ce n'est pas c'est pas la compétence du
directeur de cabinet du président d'un
public mais je crois que tout à l'heure
vous recevez monsieur le ministre à
l'intérieur et monsieur me des affaires
étrangères ans qui pourront vous donner
des éléments de réponse à ces questions
je remercie monsieur le directeur
de notre côté quand nous vous
auditionnons nous estimons que vous êtes
le deuxième collaborateurs du président
de la république que vous êtes placé
haut niveau le plus élevé dans le
l'administration de la maison d'élise et
que le chef de cabinet en rapporte
directement à vous et que les questions
politiques ne vous échappe pas
normalement et compte tenu de la très
grande importance de cette affaire vous
devez comprendre aussi que nous
souhaitions savoir si la présidence de
la république ne serait ce que dans le
but de protéger le chef de l'état de
nouveaux rebondissements à vis à vis des
ministères concernés principalement le 2
et accessoirement un troisième le
premier ces munitions de l'intérieur le
second lui sert des affaires étrangères
le troisième le ministère de la défense
d une organisation une forme
d'organisation même souple genre cellule
de crise a pu être mise en place pour
que chacun fasse sa liste rendre compte
et vérifient que absolument toutes les
mesures ont été prises pour éviter de
vous retrouver justement dans la
situation dans laquelle vous êtes depuis
le mois de décembre et nous sommes
évidemment nous mêmes aussi un moment où
nous poursuivions notre travail très
surpris des rangs bouddhisme ans qui ont
eu lieu et nous pensons qu'à partir du
moment où finalement vous obtenez
aujourd'hui une information sur le
nombre de déplacements c'est que
quelqu'un a relevé tous les déplacements
et ce quelqu'un qui relevaient les
déplacements aurait certainement pu
aussi faire obstacle à l'utilisation du
passeport diplomatique si des consignes
lui avait été donné et on peut pas
manquer de se dire c'est presque du bon
sens mais pourquoi toutes ces
expositions jeux étaient en bon français
on parle de check list pourquoi une
check this n'a pas été fait que depuis
le départ comme ça a été le cas pour les
passeports de service
on est dix pour les passeports
diplomatiques si ce monsieur qui n'est
pas n'importe qui se présente à la
police de l'air et des frontières avec
le passeport diplomatique
veuillez s'il-vous-plaît l'empêcher de
passer car nous lui avons demandé la
restitution de ce passeport diplomatique
vous comprenez notre état d'esprit c'est
pas de fin vraiment nous ne souhaitons
vous créer aucune espèce de difficulté
personnelle
nous sommes là dans un rôle fondamental
qui est confiée au parlement la rolls de
contrôle du bon fonctionnement de l'état
et nous nous demandons pourquoi ya pas
eu un peu plus de maîtrise de ce
processus qui a abouti à des problèmes
qui sont d'abord des problèmes qui sont
posés à l'exécutif et dont chacun
d'entre nous ce serait et vous le
premier et certainement est tout à fait
bien passé c'est c'est dommage que on en
soit arrivé à une situation pareille
c'est que c'est pas du tout pour vous
pousser dans vos retranchements je dis
cela mais mais nous avons du mal à
comprendre pourquoi si les choses ne
sont pas n'ont pas été faites avec au
contraire beaucoup plus d'autorité en
demandant à chacun de rendre compte et
en prenant vraiment toutes les
dispositions possibles et imaginables
c'est le directeur non c'est moi qui ai
certainement du mal à me faire
comprendre l'utilisation des passeports
diplomatiques ou autre d'ailleurs là la
traçabilité se fait au moment où on
franchit la frontière soit au départ
soit l'arrivée c'est plutôt à l'arrivée
qu'on utilise ce type de passeport
donc si effectivement monsieur benalla
et j'en ai pas la preuve aujourd'hui
j'ai des informations mais j'ai pas la
preuve à utiliser ces passeports dans
des pays africains où ailleurs ses
vis-à-vis de ses services qu'il faudrait
pouvoir donner des instructions
d'accord
vous avez le sentiment que tout n'a pas
été fait pour l'empêcher de les utiliser
mais non mais je comprends monsieur le
président mais je comprends et je suis
sûr que tous ceux qui nous regardent
s'interroge aussi mais moi je suis là
pour essayer de vous expliquer que
toutes les démarches qui devait être
fait quand on a eu connaissance de ces
éléments l'enquêté faite et que on est
dans un état procédural qui ne permet
pas d'utiliser la force pour aller chez
quelqu'un cherchait un document qui n'a
pas le droit d'utiliser il faut le lui
demander
avec des lettres recommandées avec
accusé de réception il a un certain
délai pour répondre il faut faire des
relances enfin c'est connaissez tout ça
c'est l'administration
et quand on voit effectivement au bout
d'un certain temps que ces passeports
n'ont pas été récupérées et bien ce qu'a
fait le ministre des affaires étrangères
il a saisi le procureur il a saisi le
procureur enfin dernier élément
vous avez parlé d'une task force
il aurait fallu mettre en place une
cellule de cellule de crise russe merci
c'est moi j'ai moi même j'ai employé
terminologie malheureux staller en
parlant de faits news donc j'accepte
cellule de crise
je peux vous assurer que dès que nous
avons eu connaissance vers le 20
décembre par des rumeurs et par des
interpellations de la presse que
monsieur benalla
se déplacer dans les pays africains et
se prévalait et éventuellement de 2,2
mission officielle via le canal
diplomatique
des instructions ont été données à tous
les ambassadeurs pour d'abord leur dire
qu'il n'ya pas de diplomatie parallèle
que la politique étrangère de la france
dans ces pays et mise en oeuvre par le
ministre des affaires étrangères et ses
ambassadeurs sous le pilotage du chef de
l'état et qu'on n'a pas besoin de tel ou
tel émissaire pour défendre pour
défendre les intérêts de la france les
instructions ont été passées à toutes
les ambassades et à tous les services
français qui sont à l'étranger
je vais redonner la parole parce qu'il
ya des questions qui sont d'un autre
ordre imposé à monsieur strzoda
notamment sur les activités privées qu
aurait pu avoir le super nanas et
monsieur crasse alors qu'il servait à
l'elysée dans des fonctions qui
concourait à la sécurité du président de
la république est ce que c'est madame
jourdain où monsieur
monsieur sûr merci monsieur le président
monsieur le directeur je vais compte
tenu du fait que leur avance je vais me
limiter à dos questions j'en avais
d'autres mais deux questions
première question vous avez lu bien sûr
les différentes déclarations que lieu
dans la presse concernant monsieur
benalla et monsieur kraz peu s'agissant
des activités privées qu'ils ont pu
exercer ou qu'ils auraient pu exercer
alors qu'ils étaient en lien avec la
présidence de la république ou employé
tout simplement par la présidence de la
république monsieur benalla a déclaré
d'après la presse avoir eu servi
d'intermédiaire par rapport à monsieur
vincent me plaît il est d'autre part
apparu le rôle important qu'a pu jouer
bien qu il le conteste dans une lettre
qu'il nous a envoyé monsieur kraz et
éventuellement monsieur benalla par
rapport à monsieur makhmoudov et par
rapport l'ong oligarque russe et je
voulais tout simplement vous demandez
c'est la première question quels
éléments d'information qu'est ce que
vous en savez vous êtes ici sous serment
si vous ne l'avez observé aucune
démarche de ce type pendant qu'il y
avait un lien étroit entre monsieur
benalla d'une part moins étroit mais
existants quand même monsieur crasse et
l'elysée je vous remercie de bien
vouloir nous en faire part c'est la
première question je sais que vous avez
envoyé une lettre
ce qui prouve que vous deviez avoir des
raisons d'envoyer une lettre dans le
fond
deuxième et dernière question il est
apparu que dans la réalité des faits
monsieur benalla avaient des
responsabilités stratégiques en matière
de définition de nouvelles formes de
sécurité ou d'organisation de la
sécurité du chef de l'état et qu'à cet
égard il participait à un groupe de
travail formel ou informel avec monsieur
le commandant du gspm et monsieur
bio-farina il est apparu par un article
de presse journal du dimanche que la
volonté explicite monsieur benalla était
que cela se fit eux indépendamment du
ministère de l'intérieur
l'objectif étant sans doute qu'il y ait
une organisation qui soit strictement
définies pour l'elysée par rapport à
l'elysée à la présidence de la
république
je voulais vous demander si vous aviez
connaissance de cela si cela était mise
en oeuvre conformément aux instructions
du président de la république est ce que
vous en savez voilà je vous remercie par
rapport à ces deux sites us de directeur
bien la première question concerne donc
les activités privées que monsieur
benalla et monsieur kraz aurait pu avoir
du temps de leurs fonctions à l'elysée
alors concernant monsieur b n'a aucune
information concernant d'éventuelles
activités privées exercée par
l'intéressé notamment dans le domaine de
la sécurité n'a été portée à notre
connaissance pendant la période où
monsieur bénin était en fonction à
l'elysée c'est à dire du 15 mai 2010 est
au 1er août 2010 8
d'ailleurs tout ceci est exclu de part
son contrat de travail
puisque son contrat de travail précise
qu' il est tenu de consacrer
l'intégralité de son activité
professionnelle aux tâches qui lui sont
confiées et ne peut exercer à titre
professionnel une activité privée
lucrative de quelque nature que ce soit
c'est l'article 6 de son contrat de
travail
je crois d'ailleurs qu'il vous a été
adressé à monsieur le président dans le
courant de l'été
c'est vrai dans le courant du mois de
décembre 2018
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure au regard
de rumeurs de presse et de questions
émanant de journalistes nous sommes
interrogés nous sommes interrogés sur
d'éventuelles missions personnelle et
privée qu aurait pu exercer monsieur
benalla comme consultant alors qu'il
était en fonctions à l'elysée
n'ayant nous aucune information de ce
type
j'ai effectivement écrit un courrier à
monsieur benalla le 22 décembre pour lui
demander toute information pertinente à
ce sujet et j'ai adressé une copie de ce
courrier au procureur de la république
en lui demandant de nous informer de
tout fait que révèlerait les enquêtes en
cours et qui ferait apparaître des
manquements dans l'exercice au titre des
fonctions qu'à exercer monsieur benalla
afin de nous permettre de prendre les
mesures nécessaires et d'exercer les
voies de recours qui s'imposerait donc
d'une part le 22 décembre je demande à
monsieur ban à la caisse qu'il a exercé
des activités privées et qu'il me donne
toutes les informations utiles sur ses
activités notamment les rémunérations et
j'adresse copie de ce courrier au
procureur de la république monsieur
pénale a répondu le 28 décembre 2018
sa lettre de réponse que je tiens à
votre disposition j'en lis les passages
les plus importants pour répondre à vos
questions
je vous confirme que tout au long des
fonctions qui m'ont été confiées à
l'elysée je n'ai jamais effectué de
mission personnelle et privée et que je
n'ai a fortiori jamais reçu directement
ni indirectement de rémunération
résultant
je tiens à votre disposition dans le
cadre de l' enquête interne qui est mené
l'ensemble de mes relevés bancaires pour
la période du 15 mai 2010 est aux
premiers route 2018 ainsi que la
déclaration de fat fonction adressée à
la haute autorité de transparence de la
vie publique
les rumeurs dont je suis la cible sont
dénuées de tout fondement
il est clair que je n'ai eu aucune
relation d'affaires en france et à
l'étranger avec des intérêts privés
pendant mes fonctions à l'elysée
voilà la réponse de monsieur benalla
j'ai obtenu cette réponse le 31 janvier
le lundi 31 janvier par courrier non
excusez-moi le 31 décembre 31 décembre
31 décembre lundi donc j'étais au bureau
la journée étant essentiellement
consacré à la préparation des voeux du
président république
j'ai quitté mon bureau à 22h30 je suis
rentré chez moi j'ai regardé un épisode
de columbo j'ai pris un
ça fait du bien dans la g c'était sec 31
décembre j'ai dégusté un d'allemands
1962 grand'rue
on vous félicite c'est lui d'ailleurs
quand même et le 1er janvier je suis
retourné au bureau mais et j'ai fait un
courrier au président de la haute
autorité de transparence de la vie
publique
un courrier dans lequel je lui demande
de vérifier les affirmations de monsieur
benalla ce courrier est parti le 2
janvier parce que le premier
c'est un jour férié et le président de
la haute autorité maintenant monsieur
jean-louis nazan si accusé réception de
mon courrier le 11 janvier et il m'a
fait savoir et je suis parfaitement
rassurés connaissant monsieur nadal
qu'il examinerait notre demande avec une
attention toute particulière donc
s'agissant de monsieur bénin
là aussi nous n'avions aucune
information sur des activités privées
l'idée que nous avons eu des
informations par la presse nous avons
engagé des procédures pour vérifier ses
procédures sont en cours
une question avec vous si si la
commission de déontologie
suite au fait que monsieur ben à
l'assemblée a semblé s'orienter vers de
nouvelles activités
vous savez qu'il ya une procédure vous
connaissez parfaitement monsieur
directeur
donc je répondrais sur monsieur crasse
tout à l'heure je réponds tout de suite
sur la commission de déontologie
monsieur le président s'il vous plaît
monsieur le directeur répondait sur
monsieur kraz puis sur la commission de
déontologie
il faut absolument que je permettent à
mes collègues qui ne se sont pas
exprimés de vous poser des questions
donc nous allons nous efforcer de nous
diriger rapidement vers la seconde
partie de notre audition qui risque
d'être malheureusement un peu tronquée
monsieur le président je joue je
comprends vos contraintes mais vous
m'avez demandé non mais bien sûr on est
toutes les informations je souhaite
vraiment être très prisé mais je ne
ferai en marche la question également
été très longue et je tiens à ce que
vous soyez précis le directeur alors
s'agissant de monsieur kraz donc
monsieur kraz est était réserviste de la
gendarmerie dont les services de
l'elysée n'ont pas du tout le même
statut que monsieur bénard les
déclarations successives de monsieur
kraz au sujet des emplois qu'il a tenu
durant ce durant son temps de présence
dans la réserve opérationnelle de la
gendarmerie
de 2005 à 2010 18 figurent dans son
dossier personnel de réservistes
dossier qui est gérée par la direction
générale de la gendarmerie nationale
donc je me suis adressée au directeur
général de la gendarmerie nationale pour
qu'il fasse ses vérifications
le dossier a été consulté et il apparaît
qu'aucune déclaration de monsieur kraz
ne mentionne d'activités particulières
en lien direct ou indirect dans une
entreprise privée dans le domaine de la
sécurité
durant cette période donc de 2005 à 2018
dans son dernier contrat d'engagement de
réservistes qui date du 23 octobre 2017
monsieur kraz déclare seulement exercer
la profession de responsables de
sécurité
donc dans un courrier du 3 janvier 2019
j'ai demandé à monsieur kraz de me
donner toute information pertinente sur
d'éventuelles missions personnel ou
privés qu'ils auraient pu avoir et dont
la nature aurait été incompatible avec
ses fonctions à la présidence de la
république monsieur kraz a répondu à mon
courrier du 3 janvier
le 9 janvier le 9 janvier et il m'a dit
que il n'a eu aucune activité
aucun contrat aucune rémunération
pendant la période où il était dans les
services de la présidence savoir du 10
novembre 2010 est au 4 mai 2018
il m'indique que ses activités actuelles
sont conduites dans le strict respect
des obligations liées à l'exercice de
ses fonctions passées et qu'il
s'interdit évidemment de se prévaloir
d'une quelconque recommandations de la
présidence de la république
j'ai adressé mon courrier et la réponse
de monsieur kraz au procureur de la
république
enfin par courrier du 14 janvier
j'ai rappelé à monsieur kraz ses
obligations au regard du décret du 27
janvier 2010 est relatif à la commission
de déontologie
ce qui me permet de répondre à la
question de
monsieur le rapporteur sur la commission
de déontologie je vous remercie alors
cette affaire les i cette procédure
concerne monsieur benalla je rappelle
que l'obligation de saisir la commission
de déontologie s'impose donc un genre de
cadre à quitte un service public et que
cette obligation figure dans le contrat
de travail donc dans le contrat de
travail que monsieur benalla a signé le
2 juin 2010 est en son article 6 il est
précisé que il est soumis aux
dispositions du décret du 27 janvier
2010 est donc monsieur benalla était
parfaitement informée de cette
obligation qu'il aurait dû respecter
deuxièmement cette à monsieur benalla
d'informer son ancien employeur ou son
employeur actuel par écrit lorsqu'ils
envisagent d'exercer une activité privée
cela ressort clairement de l'article 2
du décret du 27 janvier 2017 et à ce
jour depuis son licenciement effectif au
1er août 2010 8
les services de la présidence de la
république n'ont été rendus
destinataires d'aucune déclaration de la
part de monsieur benalla tendant à
l'exercice d'une activité privée
je lui ai rappelé néanmoins cette
obligation par un courrier du 11 janvier
2019 et bien évidemment si nous recevons
une déclaration de l'intéressée nous
saisirons dans les quinze jours
la commission de déontologie il convient
tout de même de rappeler que monsieur
ben ali lui-même saisir la commission de
déontologie car ce moment-là nous
interrogera bien évidemment voilà donc
premièrement c'était lui c'est à lui
qu'il appartient de faire cette démarche
par précaution je le lui rappeler
par un courrier et des kills m'indiquera
qu'il envisage de prendre une activité
dans le privé je saisirai la commission
de déontologie
merci monsieur le directeur je vais
donner le rôle aux collègues qui le
souhaitent en leur demandant de bien
vouloir respecter temps de parole limité
le ministre de l'intérieur est là depuis
16h30
nous le faisons patienter mais nous
devons naturellement mené cette audition
a bien donc je vous donne la parole
d'abord monsieur loïc hervé pour une
minute et demie merci monsieur le
président et le directeur de cabinet ma
question sa tâche directement à la
question la sécurité présente la
république et des services de la
présidence
il semble que monsieur benarab attou va
restituer un téléphone crypté et vous
nous l'avait confirmé
on sait aussi qu alexandre banal a
bénéficié d'une habilitation secret
défense cette habilitation est conférée
après qu'une enquête a été menée sous
l'autorité du sgdsn
cette enquête doit s'assurer que des
activités passées ou contemporaines sont
compatibles avec l'habilitation secret
défense dont je parle
quels éléments pouvez vous nous
communiquez sur le rapport d' enquête
qui est élaboré et aussi sur la personne
qui a élaboré cette enquête
merci
jours qu on va prendre les questions de
manière groupée
monsieur le directeur c'est plus commode
monsieur henri leroy où il prit
rapidement monsieur le président merci
monsieur le préfet directeur de cabinet
très rapidement dans votre déclaration
vous fait ressortir en enquête
préliminaire des indices graves et
concordants de culpabilité et les
enquêteurs vous entendu certainement
sans prestation de serment
s'il n'y a pas de prestation de serment
dans l' enquête préliminaire
mais compte tenu de ce que vous avez
déclaré ici je pense que vous l'avez
fait devant les enquêteurs
vous ont-elles dit où sont ils fait
savoir où le procureur vous êtes il fait
savoir si vous bien nous informer s'ils
requérait l'ouverture d'une information
qui va est d'une autre dimension puisque
il y un juge d'instruction qui est
requis
car de déclaration que vous avez de fête
devant la commission effectivement il y
à bien des indices graves et concordants
de culpabilité pour lequel vous avez été
entendu sur la sphère benalla merci
monsieur leroi madame lherbier oui
monsieur le directeur de cabinet je me
perds un peu avec tous ces passeports
passeport de service passeport
diplomatique en fin de compte
y at il vraiment des prérogatives
spéciale vraiment su vraiment des choses
extraordinaires concernant tel et tel
passeport pourquoi on en sache pas plus
il existe t'il un fichier particulier
pour chacun d'entre eux et pourquoi
monsieur de ben alla a besoin de tendre
passeport tout simplement tout à fait
naïvement
de par une fonction qui lui étaient tels
lewis le directeur parfois nous
convoquons le bon sens pour formuler nos
questions il ya parfois des sources des
zones man que je crois beaucoup de
concitoyens partagent madame esther
benbassa merci monsieur le président
vous avez déjà répondu à ma question la
question que je vais vous poser mais je
voudrais m'assurer que depuis son son
licenciement
monsieur benalla ne s'est pas rendu à
l'elysée il ainsi de cette question de
très précises chers collègues je suis
présidente kaner et merci monsieur le
président monsieur de cabinet de la
barre président me permettez moi de
compatir un petit peu avec vous sur de
tels collaborateurs mais je vous êtes
directeur de cabinet dont vous êtes le
patron de la chefferie saviez vous que
monsieur benalla était le détenteur du
seul
téléphone théorème de la chefferie
premièrement deuxièmement est ce que
vous considérez que cette situation est
conforme à halle au regard du fait que
sauf erreur de ma part mais vous ne
l'avez dit à l'époque monsieur benalla
n'était pas conçu technique ni chef de
cabinet adjoint n'était que chargée de
munitions dans l'organigramme de
l'elysée tu complète la question chez le
directeur est ce que quand le 4 octobre
téléphone théorème de monsieur bédard a
été désactivé un autre téléphone a été
attribué la chefferie de cabinet dans la
tente de la restitution de l'appareil
que monsieur bénalia a continué à
détenir et etc at on fait dans
l'intervalle évidemment madame arriver
très rapidement parce que la question
vient plus ou moins d'être d'être posée
de 0,8 inventaire de tout ce qui était
dans le bureau et vous avez constaté
qu'ils n'avaient pas de paston passeport
mais vous nous avez pas dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de téléphone
or vous n'êtes vous attendez un
inventaire général le 4 octobre pour
constater que le combiné est manquant
donc je voudrais savoir ce qui s'est
passé et est ce que en fait la méthode
de l'inventaire et systématique
comment elle aurait dû être utilisé et
pourquoi entre le de 0,8 et le 4 10 on
s'est pas étonné de l'absence dans le
premier inventaire de cet appareil se
grosdidier
merci le cependant le directeur de
cabinet lors de notre précédente édition
nous avions annoncée donc l'engagement
de la procédure de licenciement de
monsieur benalla vous nous avez dit que
c'est effectif au 1er août mais je
voulais en est absolument certain donc
est ce que cette procédure est bien
mieux à son terme et à ce qu'on aime les
éléments je dire de la notification du
licenciement le récépissé et et le solde
de tout compte pour s'assurer de
l'effectivité de deuxièmement vous avez
dit qu'il s'agissait de faits que nous
tentons par les deux polices parallèles
ou de diplomatie parallèle sur la police
parallèle simplement mais très vite vous
rappeler que vous nous avez expliqué au
départ que monsieur benalla s'occuper de
tous deux protocoles de déplacement mais
pas de sécurité puis que vous aviez
demandé un port d'armes parce que vous
pensiez qu'il était plus approprié à
sur et à renforcer la sécurité privée
que le j'espère lui même nous a expliqué
que c'était plutôt une source
d'insécurité que d'avoir quelqu'un
d'autre avec le gspr d'andoque rien
n'est clair je veux dire sur cet aspect
de police parallèle si vous et quant à
la diplomatie parallèle c'est pas dans
le champ
sinon je vous demanderais si monsieur
benalla n'a pas utilement renseigner le
président de république par exemple sur
l'activité des russes au tchad est mieux
que la cellule afrique mais c'est pas
dans le champ de la commission donc je
ne pose pas la question je voudrais
simplement vous nous disiez si le lien
n'a pas été maintenue d'une façon ou
d'une autre
et si sur ce sujet comme d'autres par
exemple le maintien de l'ordre avant ou
après le 8 décembre et les conditions
d'emploi de nos forces de l'ordre n'y a
jamais eu de à votre connaissance d'
analyse d'information des changes entre
monsieur benalla et quiconque à l'elysée
je vous remercie je vous précise que
nous avons reçu dès le début du mois
d'août la copie de la lettre de
licenciement de monsieur benhaddad que
j'ai sous les yeux qui datait du 24
juillet 2018
monsieur buffet monsieur présent merci
monsieur le directeur j'ai une question
je crains que vous dites déjà répondu à
cette question mais monsieur benalla des
de dire à utiliser au moins à 20
reprises les passeports qu'ils avaient
conservée pour voyager
savez-vous pour quel usage il a fait ce
voyage qui l'a rencontré et si vous ne
savez pas parce que je crois que vous
avez dit que vous ne saviez pas
avez-vous dit les jantes et dansait déjà
des procédures une façon enquête je sais
pas ce que quelques formes que cela se
représente pour en savoir un peu plus
merci merci cher collègue madame
eustache brinio merci monsieur
présidente qui sont très très courte et
peut-être un peu direct monsieur le
directeur vous me pardonnerez un peu
côté directrice dé ma question
vous nous avez apporté énormément
d'informations aujourd'hui certaines
sont parfois un peu stupéfiants me
suivez là lorsque j'avais posé la
question du passeport avec beaucoup
d'assurance m'avaient dit qu'ils avaient
listé dans son bureau
donc aujourd'hui une seule question
monsieur directeur pensez-vous
clairement votre âme et conscience que
monsieur benalla nous a menti lors de
son audition du mois de septembre et
sont très direct
très sont très simples c'est important
que vous puissiez apporter votre point
de vue à ce sujet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur de cabinet ma question
s'inscrit un peu dans l'esprit de la
question qui a été posée par notre
président monsieur philippe bas en
complétant celle de notre collègue tout
à l'heure monsieur directeur de cabinet
vous avez dit clairement il n'y a pas de
dysfonctionnements mais je me pose
néanmoins la question concernant cela
l'utilisation de ce téléphone crypté où
nous avait expliqué très clairement
pourquoi est utilisé ce genre de
matériel
il est affecté aux personnes qui
s'occupent de la sécurité des
déplacements du président de la
république
vous avez dit très précisément gelé
noter qu'en cas de changement de
revirements sur le programme sur le
planning du président cette personne
doit on être informé celle qui en est
détenteur et qui organise les
déplacements du président pour des
raisons de sécurité pour éviter que ces
informations fuite depuis lors depuis
que monsieur ben alla n'est plus en
charge de ce dossier
je pense que monsieur le président et
nous en sommes tous d'accord a continué
à à se déplacer il y a eu des
organisations a monté par rapport à ses
déplacements la qui en est et qui était
en charge de ces déplacements de cette
organisation
et est ce que cette personne était en
possession de cet outil qui me semble
absolument indispensable pour la bonne
organisation de déplacements du
président et pour sécuriser ses
déplacements je vous remercie
merci de votre question monsieur alain
marc
merci président monsieur directeur nous
apprenons aujourd'hui que monsieur
biennale a fait une déclaration donc
postérieure à ses activités à la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique
vous avez posé je crois la question au
mois de juillet tout doute pour savoir
si monsieur benalla en tant que membre
du cabinet devait ou pas faire une
déclaration lâche pas tvp renseignements
pris il aurait dû le faire
qu'en pensez vous aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il aurait dû le faire
et est ce que les membres désormais du
cabinet sont tous assujettis à une
déclaration à l'achat tvp merci et enfin
monsieur kerrouche merci monsieur le
président monsieur le directeur de
cabinet c'est pour être sûr de bien
comprendre vos propos et une précision
sur ce que vous avez déclarez vous nous
avez dit s'agissant des passeports de
monsieur benalla je vous cite c'est un
monsieur qui a utilisé régulièrement
défaut pour obtenir des titres officiels
je voudrais savoir une chose très simple
est ce que vous faites référence à la
lettre dont vous avez parlé à en-tête du
chef de cabinet ou est ce que vous
faites référence à d'autres facultés
corps est utilisée monsieur bénin pour
travestir des documents
directeur vous êtes mis au défi avec
toutes ces questions et d'être
d'apporter toujours avec votre souci de
précision mais aussi avec la concision
nécessaire des réponses une partie des
questions recoupent des propos vous avez
déjà tenus mais c'est l'occasion pour
vous de les préciser je commencerai par
la question de monsieur le rapporteur
sur la mission qu aurait eu monsieur
benalla dans la réorganisation du
dispositif de sécurité de l'elysée
là aussi beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dites qui relève du fantasme
monsieur benalla n'était pas en charge
de la réorganisation de la sécurité du
président de la république
cette mission elle échoit au directeur
de cabinet du président de république
sur les instructions directes du
président donc c'était mon affaire c'est
mon dossier
c'est certainement comme ceux benalla
qui géraient ce dossier de quoi
s'agit-il
président de la république a souhaité
que les deux services qui assurent la
sécurité à savoir le commandant
militaire qui s'occupe de la sécurité
des enceintes présidentielle et le gspr
qui s'occupe de la sécurité rapprochée
du chef de l'état mutualiser un certain
nombre de fonctions lesquels la
formation l'acquisition de matériel
l'entraînement les véhicules à certain
nombre d'équipements et donc le
président dans un souci à la fois
d'optimiser le fonctionnement de ces
deux services mais aussi de faire des
économies d'échelle a souhaité que l'on
réfléchisse un rapprochement
organisationnelle de ces deux services
lorsque le projet a été présenté
certains ont dû se dire que leur leur
position ou l'or
leur rôle dans dans l'institution serait
peut être remise en cause et un procès
nous a été intentée sur le style on veut
couper le lien avec le ministère de
l'intérieur alors que les personnes qui
assurent la sécurité du président un
public sont des policiers et des
gendarmes et le resteront il y aura pas
d'autres personnes qui assurent la
sécurité du prises notre public que des
policiers des gendarmes
donc premier procès on veut couper les
liens avec le ministère de l'intérieur
deuxième procès on veut créer une milice
une garde prétorienne autour du
président la république
derrière on imagine tout à fait les
logiques barbouzardes qui pourrait
porter par ce type de l'initiative et
dès que ces procès d'intention alimenté
d'ailleurs parfois de personnes qui
étaient proches du système sont apparus
bien évidemment on a démenti on a
démenti et donc je répond très
clairement la question monsieur benalla
n'avait aucun rôle dans l'organisation
de cette direction c'est mon affaire
il est vrai que pour mettre en oeuvre ce
rapprochement on a créé des groupes de
travail des groupes de travail composés
de policiers de gendarmes et de
collaborateur de l'elysée qui
travaillent directement avec ses
services pour organiser les événements
présidentielle donc il y avait dans ces
groupes de travail des personnes de la
chefferie et donc il n'était pas anormal
que monsieur des malades mais aussi
d'autres cadres de la chefferie
participent à ces groupes de travail
le dossier secret défense monsieur
pénale a été habilité secret défense
donc à une enquête qui a été faite au
moment où je vous parle monsieur le
sénateur je ne connais pas l enquête
mais j'ose espérer que la personne qui a
fait l'anc est une personne sérieuse
donc l'anc est un dû être faite
sérieusement
voilà donc je peux pas vous en dire plus
en cet instant monsieur le sénateur
leroy
vous avez employé le terme de de
culpabilité je n'ai pas employé ce terme
j'ai parlé au conditionnel 1 d'après les
informations que j'ai il aurait utilisé
son passeport je n'ai pas employé le
terme culpabilité ensuite est ce que une
instruction judiciaire va être
déclenchée je ne suis pas magistrat je
ne suis que directeur de cabinet et ça
suffit à mon bonheur
oui madame la sénatrice je peux vous
affirmer très clairement que monsieur
benalla n'est pas venu à l'elysée de
cliquer le 20 juillet 2018
il ya des registres des notes de service
ont été données à tous les postes de
contrôle les personnes qui entre à
l'elysée son figure sur un inventaire et
je peux vous assurer qu'il n'est pas
revenu
alors c'est bien ça oui monsieur
monsieur le ministre monsieur kader
pourquoi est ce que monsieur benalla
était détenteur du théorème alors qu'il
n'était pas le chef de cabinet écoutez
moi je fais confiance à mes
collaborateurs qui organise le travail
au sein de leur équipe
donc un poste comme je les dis était
affecté à la chefferie
ensuite il appartient au chef de cabinet
à son adjoint au chargé de mission de
voix qui peut l'utiliser et qui est
légitime à l'utiliser donc c'est une
répartition qui s'est faite au sein
d'une équipe très très franchement je ne
vais pas à ce niveau de détail
parce que je fais naturellement
confiance à mes collaborateurs et je
fonctionne plutôt dans une logique de
subsidiarité et de déconcentration le
monsieur benalla a été remplacé dans ses
fonctions par un chargé de mission qui
est monsieur jean gaborit et qui lui n'a
pas souhaité avoir de théorie donc donc
le nom le théorème c'est pas pour
assurer la sécurité du président un
public c'est pour avoir des
conversations sécurisé pour gérer un
certain nombre de séquences dans
l'agenda du président monsieur gaboury
considère que pour exercer sa mission
il n'a pas besoin de cet outil donc il
n'en a pas vous savez les d argent ou
quand même une certaine marge de
manoeuvre pour organiser leur travail
et heureusement
[Musique]
monsieur marc que je vous confirme que
tous les chargés de mission et j'en
remercie monsieur le sénateur sont
maintenant à ce train là déclaration à
la haute autorité au moment où ils
rejoignent
il servit de l'église et et au moment où
ils quittent des services et donc cette
donc 7
cette règle est appliquée de manière
très très stricte
voilà on m'a demandé si j'avais dit que
monsieur benalla est un menteur non non
non je n'ai pas employé ce terme ce
n'est pas à moi de a mais je ne sais pas
moi de me prononcer là dessus je chef
directeurs des titres ou telle heure je
vous ai volé les à son bord n'était pas
dans le bureau et monsieur benallal nous
a dit qu'il était dans le bureau
voilà voilà monsieur le président je
j'ai parfaitement conscience que je n'ai
pas répondu à toutes les questions bien
évidemment tous les documents note de
service courrier courriel que j'ai
évoquées voir d'autres sont à votre
disposition donc je pourrais vous les
faire parvenir
monsieur kerrouche voudrais néanmoins
occulter les réponses cette question
c'est qu'est rouge sera dite l'aide
c'était juste monsieur le directeur de
cabinet par rapport à ça c'est pour être
sûrs que nous avons bien compris ce que
vous avez dit je vous le jeu je vous
répète vous avez dit que s'agissant de
monsieur reina là c'est un monsieur qui
ce que vous avez déclaré qui a
régulièrement utilisé des faux pour
obtenir des titres officiels
est ce que ces circonstances ya la
lettre dont vous nous avez parlé ce
qu'il y allait de ses quelque chose
c'est un comportement général maintenant
je suis allé un peu loin dans mon
affirmation jeu ce dont je suis sûre
moment où nous parlons monsieur
dessinateur c'est que le document qui
lui a permis d'avoir son deuxième
passeport de service est un faux ça j'en
suis sûr bien sûr avec cet individu ou
découvre tous les jours des choses
nouvelles à dammarie b mais pas dit vous
avez dit que dans le dans l'inventaire
du mois d'août il y avait été constaté
que les passeports n'y était pas je
voudrai savoir si il a été constaté que
le fameux théorème et n'y était pas non
parce que l'inventaire a été effectuée
le 2 août à 16 heures et c'était donc
quelques jours après la perquisition et
à ce moment là on ne savait pas si le
théorème avait été saisi par les
officiers de police judiciaire
ensuite très très franchement madame le
mois d'août c'était les vacances donc
pas beaucoup de monde les gens sont
revenus au mois de septembre parce qu'il
avait besoin de se reposer un petit peu
on a un peu de travail à l'elysée et
puis au mois de septembre s'est écoulé
six mois d'octobre qu'on a constaté en
faisant l'inventaire des théorèmes dans
des théorèmes uniquement qu'il en
manquait et donc là on a fait le
rapprochement avec celui voilà c'est le
directeur je vous remercie cette
audience est maintenant terminée et nous
allons procéder à celle du ministre de
l'intérieur qui a eu la gentillesse de
patienter depuis trente-sept minutes
déjà
et donc nous lui demandons de nous
rejoindre
c'était l'audition de patrick strzoda
directeur de cabinet des manuels macro
et vous l'avez entendu d'importantes
révélations viennent d'être faites aux
sénateurs sur cette affaire des
passeports diplomatiques d'alexandre
benalla on vient d'apprendre par exemple
et bien que l'ancien chargé de mission
inde emmanuel macron les avait utilisées
20 fois depuis son licenciement et selon
patrick strzoda il aurait même
falsifiées du papier à en-tête du chef
de cabinet de l'elysée pour obtenir un
passeport de service
alexandre benalla qui avait affirmé que
ces passeports était resté dans son
bureau lors de son audition devant les
sénateurs c'était en septembre il est
contredit aujourd'hui une nouvelle fois
par patrick strzoda vous venez de
l'entendre en direct et puis sur cette
affaire pardon adua téléphone théorème
révélations du canard enchaîné ce matin
et bien selon patrick strzoda cet
appareil électronique n'aurait pas été
utilisé depuis le mois d'octobre le 20
octobre précisément les auditions vont
se poursuivre en direct sur public sénat
christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur est attendu en attendant on
va retrouver ta mme tran huy qui a
également suivi pour nous ces auditions
devant le foyer clemenceau quelle est
l'ambiance thamond viens d'entendre
patrick strzoda interrogé pendant plus
de deux heures cet après midi oui eh
bien écoutez delphine il est très clair
que alexandre benalla n'est plus en
odeur de sainteté à l'elysée qu'il n'est
plus protégé étant donné que patrick
strzoda et bien le directeur de cabinet
des manuels macron à lyncher un certain
nombre de bombes à l'instant il a par
exemple dit vous l'avez rappelé qu'avec
son pénale a utilisé une vingtaine de
fois entre le 1er août et le 31 décembre
ces passeports diplomatiques
également il a dit qu'il avait obtenu un
passeport de service auprès du ministère
de l'intérieur en utilisant du papier à
en-tête de l'elysée sans en avoir
informé ses responsables dont qu'il
aurait falsifié un document
je vous cite un certain nombre de
phrases de patrick strzoda c'est un
monsieur qui a utilisé régulièrement
défaut pour obtenir des titres officiels
également un moment où patrick strzoda
santé à
à quai il a dit je viens vous dire ce
qui a été fait quand il y a eu tel ou
tel comportement fautif d'alexandre
benalla enfin il a également nié que les
passeports étaient restés à l'elysée lui
aurait été remis ensuite par un agent de
l'elysée c'était là la version
d'alexandre benalla pour lui les a gardé
avec lui et justement est bien avec moi
il ya françois grosdidier sénateurs les
républicains vous avez assisté bien sûr
à cette audition vous avait d'ailleurs
posé des questions avec quel sentiment
sortez vous de cette audition avec un
certain nombre de révélations que l'on a
pu avoir de patrick strzoda sur
l'utilisation des passeports
diplomatiques ou de services d'alexandre
benalla écouter l'impression de grande
gêne parce que c'est encore pire que ce
qu'on pense à chaque fois alors nos
travaux vont devoir se terminer et on
apprend quoi qu'il a passé vingt fois la
frontière avec un passeport qui ne
devait plus avoir à titre professionnel
qu'en plus il n'aurait jamais dû avoir
parce qu'ils avaient été obtenues au
moyen d'un faux et il a fallu plus de
deux mois pour que l affaire soit portée
devant le parquet donc ça reste
surréaliste on nous explique que c'est
normal alors si tous les thalys
fonctionne comme ça si on peut dans
notre pays passer d'un poids la
frontière avec un passeport qu'on n'est
pas censé avoir invalides ou volés c'est
tout de même assez préoccupant donc on
est toujours dans les invraisemblances
alors lui dément en parlant de fake news
le directeur de cabinet quoi dément
l'idée de police parallèle sans
convaincre puisque on a tous et toujours
pas pourquoi monsieur benalla avait un
port d'armes demandait d'ailleurs pas le
directeur de cabinet alors même qu'il
était ne pas censé s'occuper de sécurité
quant à la diplomatie parallèle
j'ai essayé d'esquisser une question
mais enfin on peut pas puisque c'est pas
dans le champ de la commission clients
en fin de séance il s'est bien gardé
dire d'y répondre mais disons que les
zones d'ombré s'accentue encore à chaque
audition va voir si on voit plus clair
avec les deux ministres nous allons
attendre parce que l'on sent néanmoins
que l'elysée est en train de plutôt
lâche et alexandre benalla il n'y a plus
de protection il y avait quand même un
spa nombre de bombes qui ont été lâchées
par le directeur de cabinet à l'instant
mais on nous dévoile par exemple qu'il a
fait un faux parce qu'ils ont dû le
dévoiler à la justice donc c'est des
choses qui auraient pu nous être dit
plutôt qu'ils n'ont pas été dites et qui
sont dites maintenant parce qu'ils sont
bien obligés de le dire à la justice il
a également reconnu est bon également
qu'il y avait un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements qu'il y avait eu dans
les diligences un manque de réactivité
dans la demande de restitution de
matériel en mai c'est ce qui paraît
invraisemblable
parce qu'on peut manquer diligence pour
un employé lambda
enfin benalla qui était l'employé de
l'elysée qui était au coeur de toute
actualité cet été
c'est invraisemblable qu'on n'est pas
négligence oublier certaines obligations
c'est juste invraisemblable comme tout
le reste de l'histoire a remis et
lesquels également il ya l'utilisation
et bien des du téléphone théorème et
notamment sa non restitution qui ont
néanmoins il n'a pas été utilisé
c'était là quelque chose de plutôt
rassurant indiqué patrick strzoda
il n'a pas été réutilisées à partir du
mois d'octobre
parce qu'au mois d'octobre il a été
neutralisé j'ai noté entre le 1er
juillet et le 4 octobre et qu'il y avait
un journal qui montrait qu'il n'avait
pas été utilisé qu'une effectivement il
y avait été aimé par ailleurs pourquoi
la bêtise même au départ puisqu'on
apprend en fait que son remplaçant n'en
a pas
manifestement mais la chefferie de
cabinet n'est pas équipé
systématiquement de téléphone théorème
donc on pense que si lille est il
existait au départ c'était bien parce
que lui même l'avait demandé et c'était
didier à des missions quitté autre que
les missions ordinaires de la chefferie
de cabinet
merci beaucoup françois grosdidier
d'avoir répondu à mes questions alors qu
effectivement être à christophe castaner
le ministre de l'intérieur est à présent
dans la salle clemenceau il va être
également auditionné par la commission
denquête merci beaucoup teint mais
effectivement ce sera bien la seconde
fois que les sénateurs vont et bien
entendre christophe castaner le ministre
de l'intérieur il était déjà est bien
convoqué par le sénat vous vous en
souvenez c'était le 31 juillet dernier
à l'époque il était secrétaire d'état en
charge des relations avec le parlement
mais aussi délégué général de la
république en marche le parti qui
employait et bien vincent kraz beaucoup
de questions donc cet après midi pour
cette seconde audition que vous allez
pouvoir suivre dans un instant en direct
sur public sénat on voit bien que les
journalistes quittent à cette salle
clémenceau la presse toujours nombreuses
à suivre cette affaire benalla on écoute
tout de suite à cette seconde audition
avec le cieux le directeur du cabinet du
président de la république et nous
commençons cette audition en retard et
je connais vos contraintes d'agenda donc
je tenais à vous dire que nous avons
bien sûr été obligé d'aller au bout de
notre audition c'est notre devoir
pour autant je regrette que ça perturbe
votre emploi du temps
j'ai en début de séance tout à leur
rappeler dans quel cadre et nous
travaillons et les règles très strictes
que nous observons à la fois pour
obtenir les informations dont nous avons
besoin pour notre travail mais aussi
avec le souci de respecter
d'une part notre mandat est de respecter
la séparation des pouvoirs et notamment
la complémentarité et non pas la
concurrence entre le travail qui est
celui de la justice que nous respectons
beaucoup
et le travail que nous faisons et nous
le faisons avec la justice dans un cadre
qui est un cadre est tout à fait
confiant
je vais vous demander de prêter serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre si vous le souhaitez vous
pouvez faire un propos introductif avant
que nos rapporteur et nos collègues
puissent vous poser quelques questions
merci monsieur le président je ne ferai
pas de propos introductif on a évoqué
avec vos collaborateurs
les quelques thèmes que vous souhaitiez
abordé donc je tenterai le but de
répondre le plus précisément possible
aux questions
c'est le choix que nous avons fait
depuis le début de nos échanges et
depuis l'ouverture de cette commission
d' enquête au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur dont je n'étais pas en
responsabilité au début de votre
commission denquête mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'échanger par courrier à
plusieurs reprises monsieur le président
pour vous fournir tous les éléments dont
nous disposions et pour éclairer vos
travaux je vais vous préciser que sur un
des volets sur lequel je pense vous
pouvez interroger je pense aux
passeports de service qui relève du
ministère de l'intérieur le ministère a
fait l'objet d'une réquisition
judiciaire donc nous sommes dans le
cadre d'une procédure judiciaire sur ce
sujet je n'ai pas besoin de vous
rappeler l'ordonance de 58 relatifs au
fonctionnement des assemblées qui
précise effectivement que la commission
denquête ue27 ministre c'est notre bible
et en effet vous n'avez pas besoin de
nous le rappeler
j'ai moi même tout à l'heure mais
n'implique que les missions de la
justice et du parlement qui sont toutes
les deux des missions constitutionnelles
ne s'excluent pas mais se complètent je
tenais à vous le précisez parfaitement
et comme je pense que nous sommes en
direct à la télévision je vais finir la
phrase et je vais donc aller jusqu'au
bout de la rappeler en précisant ce que
je souhaite préciser c'est à dire qu'il
est prêt si il est bien prévu que dans
le cadre du fonctionnement respectifs
d'institutions il ne faut pas entraver
le déroulement d'une enquête judiciaire
en cours conformément aux principes de
valeur constitutionnelle que j'ai évoqué
mais je souhaite dans la mesure du
possible répondre à toutes vos questions
et je voulais ce monsieur le président
le soin d'apprécier justement ce qui
relève de cette séparation ce qui ne
relève pas de cette séparation
n'étant pas en mesure de savoir quelle
question pourrait être posée
évidemment cette appréciation là je ne
doute pas qu'elle soit la bonne donc sur
ces bases là monsieur le président je
serais a tenté de répondre à l'ensemble
des questions pour ce qui concerne le
ministère de l'intérieur vous remercie
beaucoup monsieur ministres de cette
excellente disposition d'esprit je vais
ouvrir les questions en vous disant que
le ministère des affaires étrangères
nous a informés que le 8 novembre
dernier vos services ont été saisis
du fait de la détention de passeports
diplomatiques par monsieur benalla afin
que des mesures soient prises pour
l'empêcher d'utiliser ces passeports à
la sortie du territoire national je
voulais vous demander quelles
dispositions ont été prises à la suite
de cette saisine du ministère des
affaires étrangères par vos services
pour que toute consigne soit donnée à la
police de l'air et des frontières pour
monsieur benalla ne sortent pas de
france avec son passeport diplomatique
alors je vais tenter d'être prêt si
monsieur le président en évoquant
l'ensemble des échanges qui ont eu lieu
non pas de ministre à ministre vous
doutez bien que sur ce sujet là ça ne
relève pas d'un échange de ce niveau là
mais entre monsieur monsieur julien
guyot qui est chargé de mission à la
direction des français de l'étranger à
l'administration consulaire
monsieur yves biscaye et commandant de
police qui est officier de liaison et
qui travaille au sein de la mission des
lycans sécuriser des titres dès le 19
octobre
en fait il ya eu des échanges non pas
sur le sujet de monsieur benalla mais
sur des interrogations sur les modalités
qui permettent de débrancher ce n'est
pas le terme juridique mais je pense que
ce terme est clair l'utilisation de
passeports diplomatiques vous savez que
les passeports diplomatiques ne relève
nullement du ministère de l'intérieur et
que ce n'est pas dans notre champ de
compétences nous évoquons peut-être
passeport de service ou là nous sommes
en pleine compétence et il ya eu donc
des échanges entre ces deux
collaborateurs sur les modalités qui
permettrait justement de mettre un terme
à l' usage pour éviter toute utilisation
frauduleuse en passage aux frontières
il ya un certain nombre des changes qui
se sont poursuivis
au fil du mois d'octobre novembre et
décembre et si vous le permettez
monsieur le président je vous remets
très l'ensemble des songes de mails qui
ont eu lieu entre ses collaborateurs le
président mentale les balayer en détail
mais le début de l'échangé tu es sur les
modalités sur la procédure qui
permettrait d'avancer
puis dans le cadre de cet échange
totalement informelle entre ses
collaborateurs le ministère acars
étrangères a fait passer 23 noms dont
deux noms étaient enfin dont deux
passeports relevé de monsieur benalla et
donc sur cette base le collaborateur du
ministère de l'intérieur indiqué que
compte-tenu de la personnalité et du
sujet assez médiatique de monsieur
benalla ça ne roulait plus des échanges
qui devra relier à ce niveau-là ça
devait relever d'un niveau supérieur il
avait invité le collaborateur en
question à saisir la direction générale
de la police nationale pour qu'on puisse
répondre à ce sujet et donc au fond s'il
ya eu des échanges qui date de début
octobre qui se sont poursuivies
effectivement le 8 novembre avec cette
communication d'un tableau qui fait
apparaître 23 passeport diplomatique +22
monsieur benalla ça n'est en fait que le
[Musique]
alors je vais si vous voulez je
reprendre précisément donc le premier
échanges portent sur le fait de savoir
si on peut annuler comment on peut
annuler l'utilisation de passeports
diplomatiques volée et ou perdus et donc
eu un premier échange sur deux personnes
qui ne concerne pas directement
monsieur benalla donc je vais vous les
remettre mais ça ne relève pas forcément
il n'y a pas d'intérêt que je vous
communique les noms ensuite le mercredi
24 octobre les changes s'est poursuivie
sur la procédure mais uniquement sur la
procédure au fond c'est une procédure
qui est que très rarement utilisé dans
les échanges entre le ministère et
ministère de l'intérieur et le ministère
des affaires étrangères le 5 novembre
l'interlocuteur de monsieur biscaye dont
je vous rappelle qu'il est c'est
monsieur guyot qui monsieur biscuits et
au sein du ministère de l'intérieur
ils ont poursuivi sur les échanges vont
expliquer techniquement comment on
pouvait intervenir mais il n'y avait
toujours pas des changes de liste puis
le nuit novembre conformément à ce que
le ministère des affaires étrangères
nous a indiqué a été communiquée pour la
première fois un tableau donc de
passeports perdus au volley au nombre de
25 23 + 2 qui relevait effectivement de
monsieur benalla compte tenu de la
présence de monsieur benhaddad la
notoriété de monsieur benalla le
collaborateur qui nous rappelle est un
chargé de mission au sein de la mission
délivrance sécurité des titres qui est
un une mission au sein d'un service de
la monnaie à ses relations publiques
donc on n'est pas forcément c'est un
collaborateur qui ne manque pas d'un
tuyau mais a minima qui est observateur
de l'impact médiatique lit les jours que
nous avons tous connu concernant ce
sujet dans qu'à ce moment là
compte tenu de la notoriété de monsieur
benalla le commandant biscaye a indiqué
à son interlocuteur d'une part qui va
les saisir officiellement à minima la
direction générale de la police
nationale et d'autre part qu'il manquait
des documents pour que le dossier puisse
être correctement instruits cet échange
a été confirmée par un échange de mails
les 20 et 21 novembre
vous me dites ah si je suis pas claire
mais j'essaye d'être précis
puis le 19 décembre là le service du
ministère des affaires étrangères a
saisi à nouveau le commandant biscaye
pour lui demander je précise je vous
serais reconnaissant de bien vouloir
porter le signalement sous les fichiers
européen de manière à invalider le
déplacement des personnes présentant ces
passeports à la paf et là il ya eu un
nouvel échange dont qui a été adressé
lui à la dgpn à cette date là il ya un
nouvel échange mercredi 26 décembre où
nos services mais là au niveau de la
direction générale de la police
nationale ont précisé que pour les
pertes des vols nous avions un
dispositif qui permette effectivement
d'intervenir mais que tel n'était pas le
cas pour les passeports qu'ils perdaient
en fait l'heureuse démission et donc du
coup le mail se conclue le 26 décembre
en disant regretter
en conséquence d'une pour accéder à
votre demande bien cordialement et c'est
donc en fait ce que je vous explique
c'est que il ya eu un échange informel
entre collaborateurs puis une saisine
formelle au bon niveau celui de la dgpn
et une réponse le 26 décembre qui
précise que techniquement le ministère
de l'intérieur n'est pas en mesure dès
lors que ces passeports ne relève pas du
ministère de l'intérieur de pouvoir
empêcher leur utilisation
sauf dans certains cas si on est sur une
procédure notamment judiciaires ou là on
a une injonction de faire et on peut
éventuellement le faire
voilà monsieur le président je vais vous
communiquer tous ces deux s'échangent
écrit sur ce sujet on a en fait un
cheminement qui peut paraître un peu
complexe mais qui est un échange
effectivement à partir d'octobre puis le
8 novembre apparaît le nom de monsieur
benhadda parmi 25 autres puis des
échanges techniques qui explique je
pourrais voulais préciser les raisons
pour lesquelles techniquement nous ne
sommes pas en mesure d'en valider un
passeport qui ne relèvent pas du
ministère de l'intérieur et dont nous
n'avons pas connaissance
[Musique]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre je
ne fais pas d'autre commentaire que
celui ci voilà comme vous le dites
justement comme le pressent le
collaborateur dont vous avez cité le nom
un dossier qui concerne une personnalité
qui fait couler des tonnes d'encre
depuis plusieurs mois beaucoup plus que
nous ne pourrions l'avoir souhaité des
uns et les autres est le seul traitement
qui fait pour l'empêcher de sortir de
france est un traitement qui reste à un
niveau très honorable de notre
administration
mais sans qu'il semble y avoir de
pilotage au niveau des plus proches
collaborateurs des ministres pour éviter
qu'on se trouve précisément dans la
situation dans laquelle on a fini par se
trouver
compte tenu des actions de ce personnage
parce que pendant que les bureaux du
ministère des affaires étrangères et du
ministère de l'intérieur correspondait
journellement sur les réglementations
applicables monsieur benalla
accomplissait 20 déplacements à
l'étranger avec son passeport
diplomatique convenait que il ya des
raisons de trouver du seul point de vue
du bon fonctionnement de l'état qui est
le seul que nous puissions avoir dans le
cadre de notre responsabilité
constitutionnelle appelle certainement d
évolution dans la manière de faire
nous avons tout à l'heure avec le
directeur du cabinet du président de la
république posait la question de savoir
si au fond compte tenu de ce qui s'était
passé il y avait eu une sorte de cellule
de crise organisée pour veiller point
par point à ce que tous les attributs de
sa fonction soit rapidement restitués
par monsieur benalla est en tout cas une
puisse plus s'en servir
et là ce sont des cadres des deux
ministères qui se renvoient la balle
pendant plusieurs semaines sans que la
police de l'air et des frontières soit
berthe et qu'il y avait une possibilité
que monsieur benalla utilise un
passeport diplomatique que qu'on lui
avait demandé de restituer dès le mois
de juillet c'est vous comprenez notre
préoccupation là dessus monsieur le
ministre je comprends votre
préoccupation mais d'abord vous évoquez
les ministres encore faut-il être saisie
avoir l'information pour que les
ministres puissent intervenir
tel n'est pas le cas qu'est ce qui se
passe avec un passeport diplomatique
vous le présentez à l'aubette vous êtes
contrôlés à l'aubette du contrôle de la
paf est une application covadis qui
rocke votre nom et qui interroge de base
le fichier des personnes recherchées
dans un premier temps et un second
fichier c'est un anglicisme health ltd
qui va interroger un troisième fichier
qui s'appelle fauve est ce qu est un
fichier qui supporte donc les fichiers
volés ou perdus mais cela ne fonctionne
pas pour les passeports invalidés j'ai
bien dit pour fovez des fichiers les
passeports qui sont volés ou perdus le
cas d'invalidation n'existe pas
aujourd'hui dans notre système numérique
électronique et donc ya pas de base il
n'existe pas de base qui permet d'avoir
cette information centralisée sur la
totalité des passeports je sais
parfaitement au nom du ministère de
l'intérieur
et m une information sur un titre qui
est émis par le ministère de l'intérieur
et qui du coup à un moment donné va être
gérée par la police de l'air et des
frontières
ça n'est pas le cas pour les passeports
diplomatiques comme c'est ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre notre système est très
opérationnelle sur l'ensemble des
passeports on y reviendra si vous le
souhaitez il ya quatre types de
passeports qui peuvent être émis par le
ministère de l'intérieur sur lequel
notre système numérique est assez simple
et efficace
en l'espèce pour les passeports
diplomatiques qui en plus ne sont pas
des passeports biométriques et qui n'ont
pas le même niveau d'information il
n'est pas possible aujourd'hui de dire
on interdit
alors on préfère un signalement
personnel mais sauf que ce ne serait pas
légale monsieur le président d'avoir
parce que monsieur ben alla jusqu'à
nouvel ordre n'a pas été condamnée est
capable de condamnation d' interdiction
de sortie du territoire
c'est déjà une information qui est
importante et nous au niveau de la
police de l'air et des frontières jeudi
nous avec un nous évidemment collectif
nous ne sommes pas en mesure de décider
qui même s'il est médiatisé peu ou pas
sortir du territoire et nous n'avons pas
l'information
quand le ministère l'a fait
étrangères et mais un passeport
diplomatique tout comme nous n'avons pas
l'information je parle en général du
fait que le passeport diplomatique n'a
plus sa fonction ou sa vocation à être
utilisé ou pas utilisés j'espère être
clair sur ce sujet mais je voudrais que
les choses soient claires le ministère
de l'intérieur
assume l'émission et la gestion de
quatre types de passeports et donc
aujourd'hui on a un système qui permet
de le suivre
par contre pour les passeports
diplomatiques nous n'avons pas
l'information en amont
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de possibilité
de dire un passeport est désactivé parce
que la personne a perdu sa fonction
d'origine et donc le ministre de
l'intérieur s'il l'a pas l'information
et s'il a pas une réquisition sur ce
sujet n'est pas en mesure d'interdire
son utilisation
voilà je veux que les choses soient
claires sur cette question là mais c'est
un principe qui pas nouveau qui est
conscient par contre on a un problème
technique s'est gelé dit on a
aujourd'hui un dispositif qui remonte à
un décret de 2005
on a aujourd'hui pour les passeports de
service on a aujourd'hui des dispositifs
techniques et technologiques sur les qui
permettent de gérer les différents
passeport qui ne permettent pas en fait
d'analyser la situation d'un passeport
diplomatique qui n'auraient pas été
perdu ou qui n'aurait pas été volé
donc qui aurait fait l'objet d'une
déclaration devant la police pour pertes
ou pour vol et ou la simple information
de l'administration de tutelle ne nous
permet pas de dire il a perdu sa
fonction
nous ne sommes pas nous autorités
judiciaires qui avait cette capacité
donc dès l'information dé ce constat et
je dois vous avouer que ce concept assez
récent c'est la première fois qu'ils se
produit semble-t-il dans nos relations
entre les deux ministères des ce constat
nous avons décidé avec jean yves le
drian qu'un groupe de travail fasse en
sorte qu'on puisse trouver des solutions
techniques
cette situation n'était jamais arrivé et
nous trouverons une solution assez
rapide pour qu'elles ne se reproduisent
pas je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre nous comprenons parfaitement
que tout citoyen français munis d'un
passeport diplomatique
non plutôt d'un passeport ordinaire et
qu'il ne fait l'objet d'aucune poursuite
puisse quitter le territoire national
avec son passeport il s'agit de savoir
si vous pouvez donner à la police de
l'air
frontières une consigne pour qu'un
individu ne puisse pas utiliser
illégalement un titre de voyage et qu'il
n'a plus le droit d'utiliser ces c'est
intéressant d'apprendre que le ministre
de l'intérieur où ses collaborateurs ne
peut pas donner de consignes à la police
de l'air et des frontières d'empêcher
l'usagé d'un passeport diplomatique a
qui ne devrait plus être détenu par un
individu pour franchir la frontière
française
simplement monsieur présent il faut une
raison juridique pour un policier pour
agir utilisation illégale d'un passeport
diplomatique et une sorte qu'il faut
qu'il ait cette information là mais
précisément ce qui nous inquiète c'est
qu'il ne l'ait pas une âme et je vous
confirme que nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui de décision qui permettent
de constater cela et qui aurait pu
permettre d'informer et en plus en un
problème informatique
je mets les deux très bien je vais
donner la parole à nos deux rapporteurs
qui se sont engagés à poser des
questions concise pour permettre à nos
autres collègues de poser à leur tour
leurs propres questions monsieur d'empyr
sur les faits observés monsieur le
ministre que dans la lettre
il nous a envoyé le 7 janvier
monsieur jean yves le drian écrit au vu
de l'absence de restitution de documents
le ministère des affaires étrangères à
la demande la présidence de la
république a décidé de lancer la
procédure d'invalidation des passeports
diplomatiques de monsieur benalla
démarche confirmé le 8 novembre au
ministère de l'intérieur
il ya donc quelque chose tout à fait
singulier devant le fait que quelqu'un
qui dispose indûment d'un passeport
diplomatique puisse l'utiliser à 20
reprises sans qu'il ne puisse y avoir de
réaction ni de la part de la présidence
de la république nous en avons eu
malheureusement confirmation
ni de la part du ministère de
l'intérieur et sans doute ni de la part
du ministère des affaires étrangères il
ya quelques gars là quelque chose de
singulier
s'agissant en plus des déplacements d'un
personnage qui comme vous l'avez dit et
quand même sous les feux de l'actualité
afin devrait quand même suscité
l'attention des ministères sans doute à
un niveau assez élevé mais question sont
les suivantes nous avons nous avons
interrogés un par écrit monsieur le
ministre sur les éventuels permis de
port d'armes délivrer des personnels de
l'elysée confirmez-vous qu'à l'exception
de monsieur benalla et bien entendu les
membres du gspr et du commandement
militaire
aucune personne travaillant à la
présidence de la république ou y ayant
travaillé depuis mai 2017 ne s'est vu
attribuer un permis de port d'armes
si la réponse était positive il y aurait
là une singularité concernant monsieur
alexandre benalla deux autres questions
vous nous avez toujours indiqués dans
votre lettre que le ministère de
l'intérieur n'a jamais été informé de la
collaboration de monsieur vincent kraz
avec monsieur iskander makhmoudov dans
le cadre de l'exécution de prestations
de sécurité privée
cela n'est-il pas en contradiction avec
le fait que les réservistes
opérationnels de la gendarmerie seraient
soumis dans le cadre de leur contrat
d'engagement à une obligation de
déclaration de leur activité
professionnelle
ne serait-il pas singulier qu'il ne soit
pas tenu de le faire
dans l'affirmative monsieur grâce se
trouvait-il donc en faute pour ne pas
l'avoir fait enfin je fais observer que
monsieur le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république la présidence
de la république nous a indiqué avoir
demandé à monsieur crasse de s'expliquer
sur les activités privées qu'ils
exerçaient ce qui montre que au moins
pour ce qui est de la présidence de la
république
la question se posait la même question
de suisse ses ministres alors je vais
revenir tout est bon en arrière par
rapport à votre référentiel sera porteur
donc je vous le redis
quand tu as été communiqué la liste de
25 passeport perdu ou volé le technicien
mais c'est pas d'un jugement de valeur a
immédiatement répondu et a même appelé
donc le commando biscaye son
interlocutrice en lui disant qu'il
s'était proposé dans un rôle de
facilitateur il l'a informé
immédiatement par téléphone que cette
demande nouvelle concernant un document
attribué à cette personnalité
particulièrement sensible que cela ne
relevait pas de sa responsabilité je
vous ai précisé le niveau dans
l'organigramme qu'elle avait et qu'elle
nécessitait à minima une saisine
officielle de la dgpn
le commandant biscaye a indiqué par
ailleurs à son interlocutrice que les
documents transmis étaient incomplets et
lui demander de bien vouloir compléter
le mardi 20 novembre son interlocutrice
a transmis de nouveau les documents dans
lequel figurent l onglet passeport
invalidé qui était inchangé par rapport
à la première constitution
le 21 novembre vingt-quatre heures après
le commando biscaye y a d'abord informé
par téléphone stelvin puis repart plus
par courriel à 13h16 madame le break qui
lui laissait le soin de saisir elle même
la dgpn sur une boîte fonctionnels
spécifiques dont il lui communiquer
l'adresse soit quoi madame le bois etc
répondait à tous 12h51 soit gmt soit
13h51
elle transmettait sa demande sur cette
boîte au plus tard le 30 nov je vous dis
ça pour vous dire qu'il ya eu une
réactivité de cet agent quasi
instantanée et de façon systématique
puis le 19 décembre près d'un mois après
son échange avec le commando biscaye et
madame bobrek transmettait la dgpn un
tableau comportant trois anglais le
premier concernant 24 passes pour
déclarer perdu le second recensant 7
passeport déclarée volée et un dernier
ne concerne plus que les deux passeports
détenus par monsieur l'accent de banhars
toujours avec la mention a invalidé lui
demandant que ces documents se signaler
ces documents sur le fichier européen de
manière à invalider déplacement des
personnes présentées à ces passeports
taf et je vous expliquais que la notion
de la validation n'était pas dans le
cadre formel de nos logiciels
d'où la difficulté mais la dcpj a
répondu le mercredi 26 décembre donc une
semaine plus tard elle a que
contrairement aux échanges informels
nous n'étions pas dans la capacité
d'alimenter directement les bases
internationales qui répondent à des
règles qui ne sont pas seulement décidé
en france
la base 6 s y est c'est la base slt des
avec ces signalements nous en sommes
restés là parce que aujourd'hui je
voudrais cette compatibilité qui est une
anomalie dans notre mode de
fonctionnement et qui remonte à bien
longtemps je pense sur les missions des
passeports diplomatiques et canaux manic
nous allons entre nos services corriger
et je ne doute pas qu'un certain nombre
de personnes ici qu'ils aient eu entre
les mains des passeports diplomatiques
étaient dans le même régime juridique à
ce moment là pour répondre ensuite à
votre question sur la question de la
présence de ports d'armes je vous
confirme ce que je vous ai écrit je ne
dispose d'aucune nouvelle information
qui me permettrait de dire autre chose
que ce que je vous ai écrit si j'avais
eu de nouvelles informations évidemment
je les aurai communiqué au président de
votre commission dans la foulée du
moment où elles mourront été donnée
concernant le rapport entre monsieur
kraz et le monsieur iskander machecoul
newdow et ça va si c'est que peu de
collaboration et est compatible je vous
ai répondu en détail je ne dispose
d'aucun nouveaux éléments que ce que
j'ai proposé par écrit et donc je pense
qu'il est indispensable que je voulais
relise mais à l'heure qu'il est je pense
que ça va durer un peu nous n'avons
aucune information complémentaire sur ce
sujet que celle que je vous ai écrit
avec tous les détails dont nous pouvons
disposer je suis dans une situation
différente concernant monsieur crasse
comme les intérieurs par rapport à celui
qui avait une responsabilité du fait de
son engagement dans la réserve
présidentielle se croisent l'as agit
comme un hors opérateurs privés qui fait
l'objet d'une habilitation qui ne
relèvent pas du ministère de l'intérieur
et nous ne contrôlons pas au ministère
de l'intérieur
les individus qui sont dans ces
activités là merci monsieur le ministre
madame jourda merci monsieur le
président monsieur liste une série de
questions techniques sur les passeports
diplomatiques et les contrôles auxquels
ils donnent lieu
j'aurais souhaité vous puissiez nous
préciser dans un premier temps quel type
de contrôles sont effectués à la
frontière sur les personnes détentrices
d'un passeport diplomatique et un
contrôle des fichiers de police et
notamment du fichier des personnes
recherchées
donc le cas échéant ces contrôles
donne-t-il lieu à un enregistrement est
il possible de retracer par ces
enregistrements le passage d'une
personne détentrice d'un passeport
diplomatique à la frontière et on
regarde de ces éléments que vous avez
d'ores et déjà dû contrôler avez vous
pris depuis lors les décisions pour
améliorer éventuellement l'information
des services sur les entrées et sorties
du territoire français ses ministres
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure le processus
le passeport est présentée de quel que
soit le passeport vrais passeports
diplomatiques et présentées il est
contrôlé nommé d'athis-mons avec ses
références par une application covadis
celle ci interrogent immédiatement de
fichiers fichier des personnes qui sont
recherchés et le smtd le slt des scènes
effet d'algorithmes va interroger le
fichier folle le fichier fob lui traite
des fichiers volés ou perdus en cas
présent aucun des trois fichiers naïté
c'est à dire qu'aucun des trois fichiers
ne dit attention il ya un problème parce
que vous y mettre dans l'année dans
aucun des trois fichiers c'est normal
qu'ils ne soient pas dans ce fichier des
personnes recherchées ne l'est pas ce
normal qu'ils ne soient pas dans le
fichier international health ltd et
c'est normal qu'ils ne soient pas à ce
moment là dans le fichier qui supporte
les fichiers les passeports volés ou
perdus parce qu'il n'est pas enregistrée
comme un passeport volé ou perdu
donc tu me manques ça ne dit pas le
fonctionnaire qui contrôle dit merci
monsieur au revoir et la personne peut
passer quelle qu'elle soit le cas
d'invalidation je voudrais
n'est pas prévu dans notre dispositif on
m'a posé une seconde question savoir
s'il existait une base une sorte de
fichier qui recenserait tous les
mouvements
aujourd'hui ça n'existe pas par contre
il ya la possibilité de faire des
contrôles sur landreau on est passé mais
cela se fait sur réquisition judiciaire
et ça tombe bien parce que si les
services du ministère de l'intérieur
voir le miz intérieur de la possibilité
d'avoir un fichier et l'accès à la
totalité des mouvements de l'ensemble
des français qui partent à l'étranger
je pense que ce serait une anomalie
démocratique que le président de la
commission des lois ne manquerait pas de
me rappeler à l'ordre
et donc aujourd'hui je ne me permettrais
c'était un clin d'oeil amical le seul
président et donc il faut avoir en tête
que par contre on a la possibilité de
faire ses recherches mais c'est sur
réquisition judiciaire est évidemment le
ministre de l'intérieur n'est pas en
mesure de le faire c'est pour ça que je
ne suis pas en mesure de vous dire
monsieur benalla à utiliser son
passeport tel jour à telle heure en
passant à t-elle guichet de contrôle de
ta l'aéroport ça n'est pas d'abord n'y a
pas eu de demande judiciaire sur ce
sujet là et je ne dispose pas d'un outil
de ce type là j'espère avoir été clair
on vous répondre merci monsieur le
ministre madame muriel jourda
oui alors vous avez été clair n'a -
monsieur me suis encore une
interrogation vous nous indiquer que
sauf réquisition judiciaire il n'est pas
possible de faire des contrôles qui
permettent de savoir quels sont les
passages de personnes détenant un
passeport diplomatique or tout à l'heure
monsieur le directeur de cabinet nous a
indiqué qu'une vingtaine de passages
avaient été relevés
comment est ce possible je ne sais pas
quelle réponse il vous appartenait
peut-être que les services du quai
d'orsay ont eu le passeport de monsieur
benalla en main je les ignore mais
sachez que le ministère de l'intérieur
ne dispose pas de ce dispositif de
contrôle de l'ensemble et je ne doute
pas que l'elysée non plus je vous
remercie
alors je vais donner la parole à
monsieur est peut-être une question me
vient à l'esprit comment faites-vous en
cas de réquisition judiciaire
techniquement pour que ça fonctionne
dans le cadre d'une réquisition
judiciaire et que ce soit impossible
dans d'autres cas alors sous réserve que
je ne me trompe pas en vous répondant ce
qu'on m'a expliqué parce que j'ai posé
la même question que vous pour préparer
cette audition est donc dans ce cas là
on cherche et individuellement
ordinateur par ordinateur les passages
susceptible donc si on sait que c'est
tel jour à telle heure on va faire une
recherche in situ sur les ordinateurs
j'ai bien compris et on n'a pas la
capacité d'avoir ce fichier central et
donc du coup c'est une procédure
extrêmement lourde mais qui évidemment
se justifie si on descend cadre d'une
requête judiciaire chez présidentielle
merci monsieur le président de questions
encore s'agissant du passeport de
service de monsieur benalla dont nous
avons appris l'existence comme vous même
peut-être hier soir mais vous étiez sans
doute mieux informer que nous monsieur
le ministre
donc il nous a été indiqué que la
délivrance des passeports de service
était géré par votre ministère
nous nous sommes posé la question
suivante
ce passeport de service at il été
demandé officiellement par les services
de l'elysée ou directement par monsieur
benalla est ce que il vous est apparu
utile de donner un passeport délivré un
passeport de service à quelqu'un qui
disposait par ailleurs de deux
passeports diplomatiques
quelle est l utilité sinon une
collection de passeport
et enfin lorsque monsieur banal isles à
lorsqu'il a été mis fin à ses fonctions
par un licenciement
est-ce que ce concert de service vous a
été restituée et s'il ne vous avait pas
été restitués quel diligence avez-vous
accompli afin qu'il le fut j'ai une
seconde et dernière question mais je
crois que vous aviez déjà posé deux qui
sont non ça c'était une question à
traiter c'est un ensemble monsieur le
président est là la dernière question à
un seul point d'interrogation elle n'a
qu'un seul point d'interrogation
nous avons eu le sentiment qu'à l'elysée
monsieur benalla faisait partie d'un
petit groupe qui avait pour objectif de
repenser l'organisation de la sécurité
du chef de l'état et monsieur benalla a
déclaré au journal du dimanche qu'il lui
semblait préférable de dissocier ces
missions e ou cette réflexion du
ministère de l'intérieur
cette déclaration vous a sans doute
étonnés et je voulais savoir quelle est
votre appréciation
ces nominés ce tracé assez fait qu'ils
ont été rapportés soude entre guillemets
dans la presse voilà c'est fini monsieur
pression sera éthique
alors j'ai commencé par la dernière vous
disant qu'à l'instant présent je me
fiche un peu des opinions technique de
monsieur bénard la subordination de la
sécurité à la fois du ministère de
l'intérieur et de la présidence de la
république
et pour tout vous dire je n'ai pas lu
cette remarque là mais s'il est libre il
est libre de s'exprimer sur deux
sections c'est pour ça que mon attention
m'a pas être démentis encore dans
d'autres fonctions monsieur ministre
voilà mais bon je préfère vous dire que
ça n'a pas vocation à peser sur les
décisions que je serai amené à prendre
comme ministre je voudrais vous dire sur
les passeports de service qui se relève
du ministère de l'intérieur que j'ai le
sentiment que toute diligence a été
faite par nos services alors je vais
préciser le fait que d'abord monsieur
benalla à deux passagers de passeports
de service
le premier avait été demandée le 29 août
à l'époque il ya une réglementation qui
prévoit cela il était dans ses fonctions
de chef de cabinet du délégué
interministériel pour l'égalité des
chances des français d'outre-mer nous
étions en 2016 c'était la mandature
d'avant et dans ce cadre là il a eu un
premier passeport puis il a
effectivement demandé un second
passeport de service la demande date du
18 juin 2018 et le passeport a été émis
le 28 juin 2018 pourquoi de passeport
peut-être que la question a été posée
tout à l'heure à monsieur le directeur
de cabinet du président vous savez qu'à
une doctrine qui existent en matière de
passeports ordinaires
on demande de passeport dans certaines
circonstances soit en cas de visa
incompatibles d'un pays à l'autre ça
peut arriver
soit pour des raisons professionnelles
vous voyagez beaucoup et le temps
d'instruction pour un visa fait que vous
me demandez ça justifie de passeport
mais paca mais je vais répondre à ce
volet là mais je voudrais que je pourrai
6 quelle est la règle mais c'est déjà
assez rare parce que je sais pas vous
mais pour ce qui me concerne je n'ai
qu'un passeport mais n'en est qu'un
monsieur c'est pour ça et donc
pour nous c'est ça ensuite qu'il est de
passeports diplomatiques c'est une
information que les services du
ministère de l'intérieur
non pas que les choses soient claires
nous n'avons pas accès à la base de
données du ministère des affaires
étrangères nous n'avons aucune
information
si ce n'est la déclaration de tel ou tel
requérants il faut que vous ayez en tête
que nous émettons 6000 passeport de
service par an et une fille de vous dire
que ce soit celui de monsieur biya ou
celui de n'importe qui ça ne remonte pas
au ministre on a fait trois mois que je
suis en fonction je n'ai jamais vu
passer une saisine de demande sur ce
volet là j'ai toute confiance aux
services donc la règle est la suivante
n'ayant pas connaissance du fait qu'il
ait deux passeports diplomatiques
le fonctionnaire qui a instruit le
dossier ne s'est pas alerté de ce sujet
là après vous avez fait une un
commentaire que je serai pas à partager
monsieur le rapporteur sur le fait de
l'utilité de rares cas de passeports sur
lequel j'ai un doute
ce que je peux vous dire et ça me permet
de répondre à une des questions c'est
que monsieur benalla à restituer via son
avocat le 11 janvier
l'un des deux passeports de service pour
le ministère nous avons fait toutes
diligences c'est à dire que dès que nous
avons eu connaissance
alors je rappelle la règle normalement
fait que et jeudi qu'il n'avait 6000 par
an
la règle est que normalement c'est
l'autorité employeurs qui a fait l'objet
qui a porté la demande de passeport de
service qui a la responsabilité de
récupérer le passeport de service c'est
pas le ministère de l'intérieur pour une
raison simple c'est que si un
collaborateur peut justifier de son
statut pour demander un passeport de
service mais perd son statut
nous n'en avons pas connaissance à
personne ne s'en va démissionner muté et
licenciés selon tous les cas de figure
qu'on peut imaginer
nous n'avons pas connaissance de cela
donc le décret de 2005 qui organise cela
prévoit que c'est l'autorité
administrative de rattachement qui a
signé la demande qui doit récupérer le
passeport et le restituer au ministère
de l'intérieur
ça c'est la règle qui découlent de ce
décret de 2005 toutefois dans le cas de
monsieur benalla le ministère de
l'intérieur a effectivement entendu
parler de la situation professionnelle
de monsieur bénard et dès le 30 juillet
à débrancher
je reprends mon terme évoqué tout à
l'heure les deux passeports de monsieur
ben ali
donc ils ont perdu ils ont perdu hélas
nous savons faire ils ont perdu
immédiatement dès le 30 juillet leur
capacité d' usage mais monsieur benalla
ne les avaient pas restitués il n'en est
restitué qu'un des 2 le 11 janvier et
nous avons via son avocat et nous avons
immédiatement envoyé une lettre en
recommandé à son avocat pour lui dire
que c'était bien qu'ils nous en est
restituée
on l'avait sollicité à plusieurs
reprises en mai qu'il en manquait un
second et on lui a demandé de renvoyer
le second espère avoir été précis vous
n'avez pas répondu sur les les
conditions dans lesquelles ce passeport
de service a été sollicitée car il a été
question d'une lettre en tête du chef de
cabinet vous avez peut-être entendu
parler de cela une lettre en tête du
chef de cabine et non signé et dont le
chef de cabinet n'était pas informé que
cela n'a pas éveillé l'attention de
votre ministère de vos collaborateurs
non pour une raison simple c'est que
c'est lui âge la lettre en question
portent la mention alors je rappelle que
l' usage d'ailleurs dans ce dossier
c'est assez intéressant
monsieur benalla s'adresse directement à
nos services et de monde
un passeport du plomeux passeport de
service nos services réagissent et 10 on
peux pas vous le délivre et il faut que
ce soit votre autorité hiérarchique qui
le demandent donc il se passe quelques
jours est in our home est une lettre qui
est un original signé et donc originale
signée c'est celle intitulée qu'on met
sur la mention si elle n'est pas signé
on vous envoie le document c'est un
document de transmission administratif
avec voilà mais sauf que c'est là où
j'ai entendu alors pour être honnête
j'étais aux questions d'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai entendu la
fin de l'audition de veau sauce fromage
entendu sa réponse est donc il a précisé
cela donc le document en question que je
vais remettre au président sous réserve
voilà de scud et ou tard parce que là on
est vraiment dans le temps ce qui fait
l'objet d'une instruction judiciaire
mais je veux remettre ce document sans
difficulté porte la mention c'est un
papier à en-tête présence de la
république qui fait demande d'un second
passeport de service qui précise le
cadre pour lequel il est demandé je vous
disais tout à l'heure pourquoi un second
bas il est précisé que c'est lié au fait
qu'ils se déplacent à l'étranger assez
régulièrement et que c'est pour des
raisons
impérieuse de services formule assez
classique et on a la mention originale
signée mentions traditionnelles donc à
ce moment là mais qui n'est pas signée
réellement à ce moment là pour le
service il a son document le chef de
service
en l'espèce le chef de cabinet de
quelqu'un qui demande à fait la démarche
le dossier est complet on une semaine un
peu moins le dossier est émis et donc il
a eu dans ce cadre là sont l'information
nous d'un point du portugal ça reste
dans le dossier dossier qui sera remis à
la justice
intégralement si c'est nécessaire et
rémy nice madame jourdain aimerait
compléter la question juste sur un point
un coin de votre réponse à tout petit
point monsieur le ministre vous avez la
copie avec mention originale signée donc
sans signature le vent au près mais
l'original ci est il arrivé dans le
dossier non attendez c'est un terme
administratif alors d'abord le vouer
tant le ministère de l'intérieur
rappelle c'est la lettre se présente
ainsi et vous avez une transmission qui
vient d'un service avec originale signée
vous ne demandez pas l'original non dans
les usages
a priori selon ce qui m'a été indiqué
dans les usages entre services c'est un
usage habituel
je vais devenir parole maintenant
monsieur grandidier s'il a une question
à poser je crois que c'est le cas à
monsieur le ministre
pardon monsieur grosdidier monsieur me
disent souvent ces précisions juste une
précision vous indiquer que nous avons
transmis à patrick strzoda qui a évoqué
un soupçon de faux à la fin du mois de
décembre et nous avons lui avons
transmis donc dans l'est et jours qui
ont suivi jusqu'à exactement quand ledit
document et ça amène à la saisine dont
il a évoqué tout à l'heure mais le
soupçon de faux nous ne l'avions pas
c'est l'elysée qui nous alertait on a
recherché dans le dossier c'est comme ça
que l'on voit apparaître ce
particularisme administratif
l'euphémisme
monsieur grosdidier oui merci monsieur
le président oui monsieur le ministre on
avait reçu votre prédécesseur et avant
votre prédécesseur d'ailleurs les
responsables quoi les dirigeants de
l'elysée que départ nous avaient tous
dit que monsieur benalla s'occuper de
tout d'organisation déplacement de
protocole mais pas de sécurité votre
prédécesseur qui n'avait par ailleurs
rien vu rien entendu et ne pouvait rien
dire nous a quand même dit qu'il avait
parfois monsieur croisé monsieur benalla
qu'il avait pris qu'en le voyant pour un
policier donc former les apparences et
n'étaient pas les mêmes
donc vous vous vous arriver mais vous
avez dû prendre le temps de vous
approprier tels que votre prédécesseur
les dossiers prendre connaissance des
personnes qui vous entourent quel est à
votre connaissance le rôle que monsieur
benalla n'avez vous n'avez pas je dire
en matière de sécurité même avant que
que vous vous y arriviez est aujourd'hui
parait t'il encore en lien avec des
membres des forces de sécurité
intérieure qui qui qui dépendent de
votre ministère et para type est par
ailleurs avec des
membre quad et certaines autorités y
compris d'ailleurs le président de la
république en matière de sécurité at il
pu ou non votre connaissance livrer même
ses propres analyses à l'occasion autour
du 8 décembre jeudi à l'occasion
d'ailleurs dû du revirement qu'il ya eu
en matière de doctrine d'emploi des
forces mobiles dans ces manifestations
par ailleurs quand je disais on avait un
c'est que vous fichez de la vie qu'ils
peuvent rendre sur les sujets de
sécurité mais ce que certains s'y
intéresse par ailleurs sur la le port
d'armes
j'ai pas con je sais pas quelle réponse
a été fait ou pas puisqu'on n'a pas
communication de réponse écrite qui ont
été faites mais ma question était
d'abord de savoir puisque il s'occupa de
sécurité qu'on lui préfet de police il
avait octroyé un port d'armes par est il
concevable au ministère au ministre de
l'intérieur que vous n'êtes que la
préfecture de police puissent octroyer
une autorisation de port d'armes à une
personne contre la vie d'ailleurs
puisque nous a été dit du gspr et quand
le dire qu'à du président de république
nous explique que c'était pour renforcer
la sécurité du président lors des
déplacements privés alors que les
experts nous expliquent qu'il est là
présent tout le temps 24h 24 365 jours
par an est ce que ça vous paraît
cohérent qu'on autorise un port d'armes
à une personnalité tiers enfin sur les
passeports
pas encore tout compris et comment
effectivement on peut utiliser 20 fois
un passeport qu'on est censé ne plus
avoir quand il dit qu'il n'y avait pas
de sources légales pas de fondement
légal pour empêcher l'utilisation sur un
passeport diplomatique est ce qu'on peut
l'utiliser quand on est plus dans les
fonctions pour la voir et puisque le
pass un passeport de service a été
obtenue au moyen d'un faux est-ce que
c'est pas un motif autant que pour un
vol de passeport pour a annulé un
passeport et en voilà oui je me
permettent de prolonger la question
monsieur le ministre pourquoi vous même
vos collaborateurs dont il pas fait un
article de 40
une fois qu'ils ont eu la conviction de
qu'un faux avaient été commis pour
obtenir le passeport de service
alors monsieur ne répondait pas tout de
suite s'il vous plaît je crois que ce
serait plus comme avant tout pour vous
même si je te proposer à mes collègues
d'enchaîner leur question de sorte que
vous puissiez globalement répondre ce
qui n'empêche pas de répondre à chacune
des interventions parce que sinon il ya
des naturellement comme vous pouvez le
comprendre des frustrations
monsieur le comte
estime monsieur le président le ministre
deux questions monsieur benalla et est
connu par tous les français et les
françaises depuis le mois de juillet
dernier
est ce que le fait qu'on apprenne qu'il
est passé vingt fois depuis le mois de
juillet la frontière avec un passeport
diplomatique ne vous interroge pas sur
le fait que si vous n'avez pas eu
d'information de la police de l'air et
des frontières sur le fait qu' il ya eu
des passages parce que j'imagine qu'ils
l'ont reconnu et qu'ils ont pu
s'interroger sur l'usagé d'un passeport
diplomatique est ce que quelle
évaluation vous faites du fonctionnement
de la paf si une information de cette
nature ne vous ai pas remonté du tout en
fin de compte tenu chez un peu abasourdi
de ce que vous nous dites sur les
passeports diplomatiques et sur le fait
que sur sorte que si le détenteur du
passeport n'est plus en position
légitime de le détenir
on ne peut pas l'annuler et la question
que je vous pose est-ce et à votre soin
de votre estimation
est ce que ces passeports sont
aujourd'hui suffisamment sécurisé
l'annuler ou donné des consignes pour
qu'il ne puisse pas s'en servir pour
franchir la frontière française à ses
versants c'est la question qui qui qui
qui vient derrière ces passeports la
sentir aujourd'hui suffisamment
sécurisée parce que c'est encore plus
important d'apprendre qu'on pourrait les
utiliser
complot dit des faux passeports
diplomatiques qu'on ne serait pas annulé
alors j'avais donné la parole à madame
benbassa mais je voudrais dire monsieur
le ministre que je retire mon complément
de questions puisque le directeur de
cabinet du président de la république
nous a indiqué tout à l'heure qu'il
avait fait aujourd'hui même un article
40 sur l'utilisation du show et sur le
sur le faut maintenant monsieur
kerrouche
il était moi bah ça mon voisin veuillez
devenez de rayer votre nom de celui qui
n'était pas arrivé la même chose c'est
terrible c'est une conspiration et je
vous dis je vous donne neutralité n'en
font débat et non de lancer une ronde
madame benbassa je vois avec joie que
vous continuez à incarner au monde et
c'est une grande satisfaction pour nous
que le nouveau monde soit présent dans
nos voilà c'est ça allez-y
il y aurais tu des échanges de messages
via télégramme entre emmanuel macron et
alexandre benalla et le dernier message
datant du 24 décembre 2018 selon les
propos tenus par monsieur ben alla lui
même sur bfm
seul selon vous quelle a été la teneur
de ces échanges c'est un quand même un
téléphone crypté madame benbassa
monsieur kerrouche cette fois bien merci
monsieur le président juste encore une
fois un élément de compréhension
monsieur le ministre si j'ai bien
compris le ministère de l'intérieur
était informé que des passeports
diplomatiques de monsieur benalla depuis
le 20 juillet suite à sa garde à vue
juste d'après un hebdomadaire on nous
dit que le 19 septembre il y aurait eu
un rapport de la police aux frontières
sur le déplacement de monsieur benalla à
londres avec un autre voyageur
et que sais tu ce déplacement aurait
fait l'objet d'un signalement à la dgpn
alors c'est juste pour comprendre
qu'elle est dans ce cas là les la pièce
d'identité qui a déclenché le fait que
monsieur benalla a été repéré entre
guillemets à lons et que ce qui a été
possible à londres ne le devient plus
ultérieurement dans le déplacement en
afrique c'est juste pour comprendre ce
qui se passe merci cher collègue madame
lherbier oui monsieur le ministre
moi ce qui m'interpelle quand même c'est
ces dysfonctionnements c'est ces
problèmes dans les contrôles de
passeport ces dysfonctionnements entre
le ministère de l'intérieur et ministère
des affaires étrangères je suis
absolument sûr que vous allez y remédier
et nous sommes quand même dans une
période de risque terroriste et
abstraction du problème de monsieur
benalla on est quand même dans un dans
une atmosphère tendue de stress au
niveau des frontières et ça me semble
quand même un peu fragile
je vous remercie madame leurs billets
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
pour répondre à ces cinq questions merci
je reviendrai malgré le fait qu il était
pas question d'utiliser un article 40 de
leurs cous au strictement aucun doute
sur le fait que le document qui vous
êtes et communiquer et est un document
valable et donc le fonctionnaire qui a
instruit et instruit correctement ledit
dossier
j'ai des questions sur le rôle de
monsieur benalla quand il était
collaborateur à présidence de la
république je me suis mise l'intérieur
je suis devant vous pour cela que depuis
trois mois je n'ai jamais eu
connaissance depuis dans ce cadre là
d'une quelconque activité d'un
quelconque rapport d'une quelconque
production écrite qui serait porté à ma
connaissance depuis que je suis ministre
et puis moi poser la question
précisément le 8 2 oui nous avons changé
la doctrine d'emploi et j'ai eu
l'occasion de venir devant vous pour
l'évoquer en aucun cas nous allons
échanger avec monsieur benalla ni moi ni
mes collaborateurs ni le secrétaire
d'état qui m'accompagnait ce jour là sur
la question de la décision de la
préfecture de police du port d'armes je
pense que c'est pas nécessaire vous
levant est de rappeler que le mystère
était sollicité plusieurs fois par
monsieur benalla
tout au long de sa carrière jeune
carrière mais pourtant plusieurs fois
est que systématiquement le ministère de
l'intérieur avec des ministres
différents avaient systématiquement
refusées pour la question de savoir plus
directement les ccsa sur la question
plus direct que vous me pose est de
savoir si le préfet de police a bien
fait de délivrer le port d'armes
moi j'ai en tête les propos du préfet de
police lui même devant vous qui avait
précisé que cette décision prêtait
interrogations et donc
d'ailleurs il a abrogé dans la foulée
considérant que cet acte était
irrégulier et donc je vous confirme les
propos du préfet de police qu'il a tenus
devant vous je n'ai pas depuis regarder
ce dossier techniquement sa décision de
retrait avant que je sois en fonction me
suffisait largement sur sur cela j'ai
une question sur l'utile plus globale
sur l'utilisation du passeport
diplomatique
je vous ai dit que nous n'avons pas
connaissance quand ils utilisent tout
comme heureusement les policiers qui
voit pas c'est un individu même s'il est
connu
même s'il est connu qui fait l'objet
d'une procédure au delà de l'homme de la
situation médiatique qu'il a connus ne
font pas remonter l'information au
ministère de l'intérieur et au ministre
de l'intérieur et heureusement les
policiers fonctionne dans un cadre
procédural précis ils agissent
systématiquement lorsque il y à une
alerte et donc si par exemple il avait
été inscrit au fichier des personnes
recherchées
ça aurait fait un hit comme on dit et
donc ça aurait déclenché une procédure
et j'aurais eu l'information mais là ce
n'est pas le cas il n'est pas dans aucun
fichier
il n'a pas d'interdiction de sortie du
territoire et donc qui produit un
document qui reste légale alors qu'il
n'a plus le droit de l'utiliser c'est la
différence référence et le fait qu'il
n'ait plus le droit d'utiliser comme
tous les bénéficiaires d'un passeport
diplomatique et je le dis d'ailleurs à
tous ceux qui pouvaient m'entendre
ici ou ailleurs qui aurait un passeport
diplomatique qu'ils auraient études dans
des fonctionnaires global qui est voilà
en fait on oublie de rendre souvent
alors que quand on prend un passeport
diplomatique comme ministre j'ai été
doté d'un passeport des pratiques vous
signe un papier comme quoi vous vous
engagez à restituer le passeport
diplomatique et donc du coup c'est toute
la difficulté est là il n'a pas le droit
de l'utiliser mais pour la jambe qu'il
contrôle
il attend qu il a encore un caractère
légal tant qu'il n'est pas inscrit sur
les différences
shell est donc je leur dis évidemment
monsieur benalla n'était pas sous
surveillance
il s'est déplacé il est libre de se
déplacer et le ministère de l'intérieur
n'a pas vocation à enregistrer ce sortie
du territoire particulièrement et en
faire état au ministre de l'intérieur
je vous dirais heureusement et donc
c'est la remarque aussi la réponse que
je peux faire sur les vins passage à
l'art auprès de la paf la paf n'a pas à
le faire remonter
voilà il ya une question sur la sécurité
suffisante des passeports diplomatiques
nombreux ne sont pas biométrique et je
pense et je laisse jean yves le drian
vous réponde à cette question qu'il faut
effectivement qu'on renforce la sécurité
des passeports diplomatiques
même si je pense que peu de
bénéficiaires de passeport diplomatique
je réponds à votre question qui ont fait
l'objet
vous savez que les raisons pour un
passeport diplomatique sont limitées
peut-être qu'à la commission des
affaires étrangères du sénat on doit
pouvoir en bénéficier les ministres en
bénéficient je pars en tête toute la
liste mais voilà il ya assez peu de
risques qu'on ait des personnes qui
commettent des actes terroristes ni
ancien ministre ni ministre en fonction
je dit ça sous le regard inquiet de
monsieur kenner et donc je ne suis pas
trop inquiet sur le fait qu'on n'ait pas
de difficulté de ce côté là
y at il eu un message entre monsieur
macro monsieur alexandre d'ennahda je
n'en sais strictement rien et je n'ai
pas vocation à le savoir
j'ai lu dans la presse un certain nombre
de choses comme vous mais vous savez on
dit que miss d'intérieur et le premier
flic de france et qu'il est très bien
informé
n'imaginez pas le nombre d'informations
dont il ne dispose pas et elles sont
importantes
l'information monsieur carouge
l'information du passeport diplomatique
le 20 juillet la réponse est non le
ministère a eu je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure une liste de 25 noms de
passeports 25 références de passeports
diplomatiques dont deux concernés
monsieur benalla le 8 novembre
et c'est là où ont commencé les échanges
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
l'information selon laquelle la paf
aurait fait un rapport sur un
déplacement de monsieur benalla à
londres j'en ai aucune connaissance et
et rien ne m'a été précisée sur sur ce
sujet le concernant par contre et je
vais vous répondre partiellement mais
vous comprendrez pourquoi
par contre j'aurais eu l'information
s'ils étaient accompagnés d'une personne
qui est par exemple aurait été dans un
des fichiers fichier s au fichier des
personnes recherchées
je crois l'avoir lu dans la presse ah
mais je veux pas me prononcer parce que
c'est un article de presse et j'ai pas
plus d'un an que ça et donc c'est
uniquement dans ce cadre là c'est parce
que une personne aidant un fichier de
type fichier est ce qu'à ce moment-là ça
it et que la l'information remonte pour
tout vous dire le remontoir ministre
heureusement mais l'information remonte
et c'est ce que je vous dis depuis le
début il ya une alerte
s'il ya une alarme on a un dispositif
sécurisé pour les alarmes
on a une fragilité fonctionnel sur le
passeport diplomatique qu'il nous faudra
résoudre
ultime question de madame trunk les qui
vient de se manifester
oui c'est le président monsieur le
ministre je me posais la question vous
disais que le système fonctionne à
partir du moment où un passeport est
signalée volée ou perdue dans la mesure
où monsieur vinolas n'avait plus droit
d'utiliser est-ce qu'on est ce qu à
aucun moment votre votre autorité ou
l'elysée aurait pu porter plainte et
dire voilà ces passeports sont volés
parce qu'on les a réclamés à l'intéressé
et nous les a pas remis c'est pas un vol
vous sens juridique vous allez me
répondre et sans doute avez vous raison
mais vous pensez pas que par ce biais de
là on aurait pu quand même pas réagir
celui-ci vous voyez la réponse que nous
pouvons être amenés à faire à cette zone
de propositions compte tenu de ce que du
court stato la remarque ce qu'il faut
qu'on crée techniquement une troisième
catégorie
il faut qu'on ait une convergence je
vais même aller plus loin je sors un peu
de l'édition mais il faut qu'on ait une
convergence de fichiers et qu' on n'est
pas une distinction entre les fichiers
des passeports diplomatiques émis par le
quai d'orsay et ce par le ministère de
l'intérieur
c'est une anomalie dont nous avons
conscience et je le trion et sur
laquelle nous allons travailler ensuite
la vraie difficulté c'est que la
directive qui organise padirac et vos
sens juridique européen mais la
directive qui organise dans ses
procédures de retrait elle doit
s'appuyer sur un acte qui a une
dimension judiciaire
quand vous déclarez la plainte pour
perdue ou volée d'ailleurs on le fait
pour des papiers d'identité
c'est ce qui permet justement de
reproduire quelque chose et c'est la
différence avec la déclaration de dire
non c'est plus mon collaborateur cirque
là on rentrerait dans un une relation
d'ordre privé même si on est sur un
espace public que le ministère a pas
vocation c'est pour ça que je me suis tu
il ya une difficulté qui n'est pas
normal
enfin je personnes des doutes là dessus
c'est un dysfonctionnement qu'il nous
faut corriger
madame jour d'appui monsieur buffet oui
monsieur mais je me permets d'insister
sur le point qu'a soulevé 23 10 100e
sans aller jusqu'à une plainte pour père
pour vol en fin ou un signalement
lorsqu'un salarié quitte ses fonctions
et qu'il ne restitue pas ces moyens de
travail l'employeur peut parfaitement
saisir une juridiction compétente pour
lui faire restituer les moyens sous
astreinte
je n'imagine pas que un collaborateur de
l'elysée puisse partir sans qu'une
procédure adéquate peut être mise en
oeuvre
personne n'a songé un moment à un autre
et ça donnait dès lors un fondement
légal pour obtenir la restitution
si une décision de justice étaient
prises mais bien sûr qu'on y a songé je
vous ai fait étape de l'ensemble des
échanges techniques qui ont eu lieu du
dernier mail sur ce sujet et et du fait
qu'on a la possibilité de forcer la
machine entre guillemets donc
aujourd'hui de toute façon les
passeports diplomatiques de monsieur
benalla ne sont plus en fonction
et donc il pourrait les utiliser
visuellement pour un contrôle visuel si
je sais pas si les a rendus ou pas je
puisse en tête voilà mais mettons on a
eu un dysfonctionnement dans les
échanges et en un dysfonctionnement
technique mais il sera réglé et je ne
doute pas il faut juste que vous ayez en
tête que même si monsieur benalla est un
sujet important qui justifie que deux
ministres soient convoqués devant vous
cet après midi la gestion des passeports
diplomatiques ne relève plus ni de vous
ni de nous et je suis pas péjoratif en
disant cela et donc je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui que ce soit jean yves le
drian vous pourrez lui poser la question
dans quelques minutes ou moi même si on
avait une alerte parce que ces alertes
ne remonte pas au ministre classiquement
sur les passeports diplomatiques le
nombre de personnes qui ont des
passeports de service où on appelle le
chef l'employeur qui donne l'information
et de passeport diplomatique pour des
anciens ministres ou autres qu'ils ne
sont pas restitués je suis sûr que le
chiffre est élevé j'ai aucune
statistique là-dessus mais je suis sûr
il n'empêche que maintenant on sait
qu'il ya un problème et je suis
convaincu que pour jean yves le drian
comme coupe pour moi il n'y aura plus
aucun trou dans la raquette
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
vous avez compris que
le sens de nos questions c'était de
comprendre pourquoi
compte tenu de l'extrême sensibilité de
tous se tournent autour du licenciement
de monsieur benalla pour faute
ne nous étonnons pas que les
fonctionnaires n'est pas donnée alerte
mais plutôt que les autorités
gouvernementales n'ai pas mis les
fonctionnaires en situation de vigilance
sur l'utilisation pour franchir la
frontière de ces documents de voyage
mais j'entends bien votre vos
explications
mais si vous voulez nous nous réveillons
parfois des questions qui peuvent
apparaître comme des questions de bon
sens et c'est étonnant dans
l'application de cette sanction qu' il
n'y ait pas eu une vérification
systématique et des réactions rapides
des diligences efficace pour obtenir la
restitution plus rapidement et empêcher
les usages du document monsieur buffet
si monsieur le ministre monsieur strzoda
nous a indiqué tout à l'heure que
monsieur b dallas avait utilisé à 20
reprises au moins les passeports qu'il
avait conservé une illégalement
d'ailleurs pour se rendre entre le
propos se déplacer entre le 1er août et
le 31 décembre dernier
savez vous où il est allé et pour quelle
raison il a fait ses voyages si vous ne
savez pas avez-vous diligenter des
instructions aux services pour qu'ils
puissent déterminer la destination et
les motifs de ces déplacements coûtent
cher ministre monsieur le président vous
dire que pour ce qui relève du ministère
de l'intérieur des titres émis par le
ministère je pense que nous avons fait
mieux que des vérifications
systématiques et des interventions
rapides
je voudrais rappeler que pour les deux
passeports de service qui avait été
menée par le ministère ils ont été et
l'autre annuler les procédures ont été
signalés nous ont saisis l'elysée
immédiatement pour qu'il réclame la
restitution des passeports et dès le 30
juillet il n'était plus opérants je vous
signale que c'est le premier route
qu'eux
il ya eu ceux là mais on a considéré
lisez comme un employeur comme un autre
et on a fait la procédure sur ce sujet
deuxième élément pour les passeports
diplomatiques il n'appartient pas au
ministère de l'intérieur de les gérer et
nous ne sommes pas en mesure de le faire
ensuite savoir si compte tenu des
voyages nous avons dirigé une enquête
non parce que la police judiciaire n'est
pas sous l'autorité du 1001 à l'autorité
de la justice et donc il faut qu'ils
saisine judiciaire et donc si j'avais
fait cela si j'avais demandé aux
services d'essayer ce que j'expliquais
on procède tout à l'heure de
m'identifier les déplacements etc
j'aurais juste enfreint toutes les
règles qui organise la police dans ce
pays et toutes les doigts que vous
pouvez voter donc la réponse est non sur
les informations pour les voyages et non
je n'ai pas diligente dingue d'en quête
pour connaître les destinations de
monsieur benalla pendant cette période
je rappelle que monsieur bénard est la
seule responsabilité de la police et
donc de miser l'intérieur c'est monsieur
b d'année pas aujourd'hui interdits de
sortie du territoire
il est libre de voyager et donc nous
n'avons pas vocation au ministère de
l'intérieur à connaître des voyages des
gens qui sont libres de voyager et
heureusement je vous remercie
sur ministre et si vous aviez eu des
raisons indépendamment de toute enquête
conduite par la police judiciaire de
mettre en oeuvre des mesures de police
administrative pour surveiller les
activités de monsieur benalla vous ne
nous le dira y est peut-être pas avoué
parce que vous êtes des responsabilités
sur ces sujets là parce que préside en
mai mais effectivement je pourrais pas
l'évoquer je pourrais pas l'évoquer mais
je pourrais parfaitement vous dire que
ce n'est pas le cas je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
cette audition est donc maintenant
achevé merci d'avoir contribué par vos
réponses à éclairer la commission des
lois du sénat
nous allons maintenant recevoir monsieur
jean yves le drian le ministre des
affaires c'était à l'audition de
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a été entendu pendant
plus d'une heure par les sénateurs de la
commission des lois doté à des
prérogatives d'une commission d' enquête
sur cette affaire pénale art qui est en
train de tourner à cette affaire des
passeports diplomatiques mais aussi les
passeports de service
daul ancien chargé de mission de
l'elysée on voit de révélation en
révélation on a d'ailleurs appris par
patrick strzoda lors si le charge le
directeur de cabinet à des manuels macro
et bien que alexandre benalla avait
utilisé vingt fois à ces passeports
depuis son licenciement et christophe
castaner qui a été interrogée sur et
bien l'utilisation de ces passeports en
tant que ministre de l'intérieur
responsable de la police de l'air de aux
frontières on va tout de suite retrouvé
atteinte rami qui a également suivi pour
nous ces auditions sur toujours à cette
ambiance tam est ce que les sénateurs
ont eu les réponses à leurs questions
vous l'avez dit delphine une audition à
l'instant plus brèves un de christophe
castaner que celle que l'on a pu avoir
auparavant du directeur de cabinet
patrick strzoda et qui a beaucoup porté
sur l'utilisation des passeports
diplomatiques mais aussi des passeports
de service
on a appris avec cette audition que il
ya quelque part le ministère de
l'intérieur et le quai d'orsay semble
fonctionner en silo en tout cas sur la
question des passeports diplomatiques à
1 n'est pas possible d'invalider un
passeport diplomatique pour le ministère
de l'intérieur puisque ces passeports
relève du quai d'orsay
il n'est pas possible de bloquer leur
passage au niveau de la police de l'air
et des frontières
et pendant ce temps là à d'ailleurs dit
philippe bas et bien alexandre bonnet la
faisait donc une vingtaine de
déplacements à l'étranger avec ces
passeports
on a bien compris à travers cette
audition qu'il n'y avait aucune été dans
aucun des fichiers vérifié par la police
de l'air et des frontières
il y avait un problème technique est
aussi un problème informatique a dit le
ministre de l'intérieur qui a jugé qu'il
y avait là une anomalie qu'il fallait
peut être corrigé également bien une
autre chose à propos cette fois ci du
passeport de service qui a été demandé
par alexandre benalla au ministère de
l'intérieur sur du papier à en tête sans
que le chef de cabinet en soit informé
il a bien dit que alexandre reynal avait
utilisé un papier à en tête avec la
mention originale signée mais sans
signature pour obtenir ce passeport est
donc sans l'avoir demandé au chef de
cabinet donc une audition très
intéressante mais tout de même bien loin
des différentes boom qui ont été lâchées
par patrick strzoda alexandre benalla
vous l'avais dit à utiliser une
vingtaine de fois entre le 1er août et
le 31 décembre ces passeports
diplomatiques également vous l'avait dit
il l'a obtenue est bien le passeport de
service auprès du ministère de
l'intérieur en utilisant du papier à
en-tête de l'elysée sans avoir informé
ses responsables à l'elysée même et
justement nous allons parler d'eux cette
audition de christophe castaner avec
jacqueline eustache brinio sénatrice et
les républicains vous aviez été et bien
la première à avoir parlé de ces
passeports diplomatiques
alexandre benalla est-ce que eh bien
vous avez jugé les réponses de
christophe castaner satisfaisante sur le
fait notamment et bien que le ministre
de le ministère de l'intérieur ne
pouvait pas bloquer l'utilisation de ces
passeports diplomatiques je crois ce
qu'on avait vu aujourd'hui c'est un
grand moment parce que on a appris
d'abord plein d'informations d'abord par
le directeur du cabinet du président la
république
on a découvert que monsieur b dallas
rentrait et sortait de france avec des
passeports diplomatiques alors qu'il est
sensé pu en avoir une vingtaine de fois
nous at il révélé
vingt fois donc voilà c'est une espèce
de romans fleuves cette histoire triste
parce que voilà c'est quand même une
histoire qui se gère au plus haut niveau
de l'état
au niveau de la présence d'un public et
ça pose quand même de graves questions
sur les dysfonctionnements que promet
moment cette mission d'information va
poser lors de son compte rendu et de
sons de ce que des éléments que nous
allons écrire aujourd'hui sincèrement je
crois que c'était encore plus
interpellant que ce qu'on a vécu lors
des auditions de la rentrée et et du
mois de juillet plus on avance dans
cette affaire plus on découvre des
choses qu'on n'imaginait pas clairement
clairement et voilà et quand j'ai posé
la question à savoir si monsieur bin
hammam avait menti
on peut quand même aujourd'hui sans
trahir un certain nombre de choses
rappelle qu alexandre benalla avait dit
qu'il avait laissé ses passeports dans
son bureau et qu'un agent de l'elysée
lui avait ensuite remis à ses parents
pour nous quand il avec beaucoup
d'aisance et d'affirmation unis mois
mais passeport voilà je les ai pu ça me
concerne plus c'est une histoire classe
et on s'aperçoit que
c'en est autrement donc vraiment c'est
aujourd'hui l'addition à la porte encore
des interrogations
peut-être encore plus inquiétante les
plus graves de dysfonctionnements que ce
qu'on a pu imaginer donc je pense qu'on
en tirera des conclusions avec le
président bas se positionnera par
rapport à ces dysfonctionnements ont
jugé que le sénat aujourd'hui c'est à
dire la justice par exemple bien sûr ce
parjure vous étiez l'auteur de cette
question alors il appartiendra au
président m'a évidemment de poser cette
question aussi clairement mon mot à
titre personnel je pense
qu'effectivement il ya des choses sur
lesquelles il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin que les interrogations et donc
saisir la justice
probablement bresse et il ne
m'appartient pas à moi de le dire
aujourd'hui comme ça mais pour moi oui
je pense qu' il faudra qu'il y ait
aujourd'hui des voiles à des procédures
judiciaires qui prend fin en tout cas il
ya des procédures aujourd'hui de toute
façon qu'ils sont en cours un bon donc
du coude ou la limite d'un certain
nombre de questions d'ailleurs pour nous
on est dans un cas très précis mais je
pense que cette histoire dé loin d'être
fini pour revenir et bien sûr ce qu'a pu
annoncer de fautes alors que christophe
castaner à ce que vous avez été étonné
que le ministère de l'intérieur ne
puisse pas empêché et bien alexandre
benalla avec un passeport diplomatique
de franchir les frontières
ça c'est extrêmement interrogeant parce
que le moindre délinquants le moindre
personne suspectée on peut l'arrêter la
frontière la lui non il est passé à
travers toutes les mailles du filet moi
je peux comprendre que lorsqu'ils
passaient les frontières depuis
septembre tout le monde connaissait
monsieur bénard je pense qu'à part un
français qu'il ne le connaît pas et
qu'il appartenait pas évidemment l agent
de aux policiers qui étaient là de se
poser des questions si on ne lui avait
pas donné d'instructions précises par
rapport à ces messieurs benalla remet
donc monsieur benalla ils voyageaient a
priori tout à fait tranquillement
travers le monde pour y faire quoi
d'ailleurs
tu penses que a aussi posé va falloir se
poser aussi ce type de question que
faisait-il à travers le monde avec son
passeport diplomatique
c'est une question à laquelle il faudra
aussi répondre qu'il y à une anomalie
dans le venant le fonctionnement de ces
passeports diplomatiques aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont insuffisamment sécurisé et
puis qu'il n'y a pas de suffisamment de
dialogue entre le quai d'orsay et le
ministère de l'intérieur peut-être comme
l'a dit le ministre
c'est un buteur c'est la preuve fois
qu'il arrive
un événement pareil donc effectivement
c'est peut-être la première fois qu'on
se pose la question sur la sécurisation
d'assam dans le choses parce que d'une
manière traditionnelle et légal
voilà ça ne se passe jamais comme ça là
aujourd'hui c'est un précédent alors que
l'on voit jean yves le drian le ministre
des affaires étrangères qui va bientôt
faire son entrée dans cette fameuse
salle clemenceau juste une question
d'ajustement pour vous interroger sur ce
qui vous reste a demandé au ministre des
affaires étrangères que l'on n'a pas
entendu jusqu'ici qu'est ce que vous
attendez de cette audition sur les
passeports diplomatiques passeport
diplomatique et puis quels étaient ses
missions que faisait monsieur pénale à
travers le monde avec des passeports
diplomatiques par là qu'il l'envoyait et
pourquoi faire ça c'est une véritable
question
merci beaucoup jacqueline eustache
brinio d'avoir répondu à mes questions
alors que delphine et bien cette
audition de jean yves le drian qui vient
clôturer et bien ces trois auditions
aujourd'hui sur la sphère benalla va
débuter d'un instant à l'autre puisque
le ministre des affaires étrangères
vient de faire son entrée dans cette
fameuse 5 les morceaux merci beaucoup
tam effectivement on va suivre
l'audition de jean yves le drian le
ministre des affaires étrangères en
direct sur notre antenne beaucoup de
question pour lui après les premières
auditions vous avez pu les suivre de
patrick strzoda le directeur de cabinet
et d'emmanuel macron et celle de
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur sur ces passeports
diplomatiques on a appris qu alexandre
benalla c'était les avait utilisé une
vingtaine de fois depuis son
licenciement alors quelles ont été les
destinations à les pays dans lesquels
s'est rendu alexandre benalla voilà des
questions qui sont restées en suspend
pas être extradé à tout comme christophe
castaner ont renvoyé à les sénateurs et
bien à cette audition très attendue de
jean yves le drian c'est la première
fois que le ministre des affaires
étrangères va s'exprimer devant la haute
assemblée
dans le cadre de cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur la sphère
benalla et puis lundi c'est alexandre
benalla lui même qui va revenir devant
le sénat pour une seconde
dition elle sera bien entendu diffusé en
direct sur notre antenne
en attendant on écoute tout de suite à
les explications de jean yves le drian
sur ministériel depuis près de sept ans
mais enfin il faut bien sûr qu'ils
soient photographiés en situation et je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre je
veux revenir brièvement sur ce que j'ai
dit en commençant cette après midi
cette série d'auditions surtout sur sur
trois points
bien sûr nous avons avant tout besoin
que la lumière soit faite sur un certain
nombre de questions parmi lesquels les
conditions dans lesquelles l'utilisation
d'un passeport diplomatique qui était la
tribu d'une fonction qui a pris fin le
24 juillet dernier n'a pas pu être
empêchés pendant de longs mois puisque
même on a pu apprendre tout à l'heure du
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république que ce passeport diplomatique
aurait été utilisé à 20 reprises depuis
le 1er août dernier
c'est un sujet de préoccupation nous
avons d'autres questions nous les avons
posées notamment au directeur du cabinet
du président de la république ainsi
qu'au ministre de l'intérieur il ya dans
le fonctionnement de l'état des
éclaircissements dont nous avons besoin
pour mener à bien notre tâche sur
l'exécution d'une sanction qui a été
infligé à monsieur benalla au mois de
juillet dernier
comme nous en avons l'habitude gd
rappelé tout à l'heure nous veillerons
bien entendu à respecter le mandat qui
nous a été donnée par le sénat et j'ai
indiqué à mes collègues que ce qui
touche à la diplomatie de la france et à
la nécessité de préserver nos intérêts
fondamentaux face aux risques de
divulgation d'informations
confidentielles au bénéfice d'intérêts
étrangers n'est pas de notre ressort
même si comme tous nos concitoyens
et nous avons le droit d'être préoccupés
des raisons pour lesquelles des chefs
d'état étrangers et des hommes
d'affaires
eux aussi étrangers paraissent porter un
tel intérêt à monsieur benalla alors que
somme toute sa fonction à l'elysée était
une fonction de rang apparemment modeste
mais notre mandat porte sur les
questions de sécurité au sens le plus
strict du terme et sur les sanctions aux
manquements observés dont font partie le
licenciement de monsieur benalla et avec
son licenciement
le retrait effectif de tous les
attributs de son ancienne fonction et
nous veillons également mais ça va de
soi mais comme beaucoup de choses qui
vont de soi ça va encore mieux en le
disant à ne pas interférer avec le
fonctionnement de la justice
ça n'empêche pas que nous posions des
questions auxquelles la justice peut
s'intéresser mais dans un tout autre
objectif la justice elle recherche des
infractions et le cas échéant les
sanctionne nous recherchons une bonne
connaissance du fonctionnement de l'état
pour faire ensuite la vérité d'une part
et d'autre part faire des propositions
pour améliorer le fonctionnement de
l'état et prévenir des
dysfonctionnements que nous pourrions
constater et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le coeur de cette audition
portera non pas sur l'utilisation du
passeport diplomatique de monsieur
benalla à l'étranger et les rencontres
qu'il peut avoir à l'étranger mais sur
les diligences qui ont été accomplis par
les services du gouvernement pour que le
retrait de ces passeports soient
effectifs voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire en commençant cette audition je
vous propose si vous le souhaitez de
prendre la parole
un instant mais avant je me dois de vous
faire prêter serment
je vous invite à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et dit je le jure je le
jure je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole comme
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs pourraient
revenir sur quelques points
en complément des des réponses à vos
premières interrogations pour lesquelles
je vous avais déjà répondu par écrit le
2 août dernier puis pu le 7 janvier
d'abord sur la délivrance des passeports
premiers points comme je voulais indiqué
par mon courrier du 2 du 2 août
monsieur benalla au moment où il a été
mis fin à ses fonctions juillet 2018
était en possession de deux passeports
diplomatiques délivrés par mon
département le premier délivrer le 20
septembre 2017 est valable jusqu'au 19
septembre 2022 et le second délivré le
24 mai 2018 est valable pour la même
période ce second passeport prenez la
suite d'un premier passeport d'un
premier document datant lui de juin 2017
et qui était parvenue à échéance
comme vous le savez et je vous adresser
à cet égard un tableau il est
relativement classique que et des
membres du cabinet du président de la
république mais d'autres aussi
bénéficient de deux passeports
dès lors que leurs fonctions les
conduisent à effet que des missions
l'étranger régulièrement cela permet de
disposer en permanence au moins d'un
passeport pendant que le second est en
attente d'obtention d'un visa
ça se fait extrêmement régulièrement il
conduit compris
comme sa femme et quatre beaucoup mais
je me suis responsable que de ce1 porter
très bien je parle que des passeports
diplomatiques qui sont de ma compétence
et par ailleurs il ya aussi des parfois
des difficultés auraient été dans un
pays puis dans un autre il vaut mieux
l'éviter surcharge les acquis pour est
un visa peut on empêcher un autre donc
cette pratique là est assez est assez
courante et elle est généralement
nécessaire pour l'opérationnalité des
des acteurs voilà sur le premier point
que je voulais et fauqué et il n'y a
donc pas en la matière de jeu sans passe
droit particulier qui a été effectué à
l'égard de monsieur benalla java il va
de soi que mes services ignoraient le 24
mai 2018 que monsieur benalla avait été
suspendu de certaines de ses fonctions
lorsqu'il a il ya eu une lettre la
reproduction d'un de l'anneau de l'âme
d'un passeport de deuxième deuxième
élément rapide d'informations pour votre
commission quels ont été les démarches
conduite par mon ministère pour obtenir
la restitution des passeports des tenues
fin juillet 2018
j'ai abordé déjà cette question dans le
les réponses écrites que je vous ai fait
parvenir d'abord rappeler comme il est
prévu habituellement monsieur benalla a
signé un engagement de restitution de
ces passeports dès le terme de sa
mission est le plus récent engagement
étant daté du 23 mai 2018 au moment où
il a eu son renouvellement de passeport
par ailleurs dès le 26 juillet le bureau
des visas du ministère adressée à
monsieur benalla par lettre recommandée
avec accusé de réception une demande de
restitution de ces passeports
dès le 26 juillet c'est à dire cinq
jours avant la fin officielle de ses
fonctions puisque
la fin officielle de ses fonctions et
des mises en oeuvre qu'à partir du 1er
août
nous avons adressé deux lettres
recommandées ces adresses en
ile-de-france et dans l'eure et ce
deuxième courrier dans l'eure a été
réceptionné par un mandataire de
monsieur bénin le 6 août en l'absence de
réponse et de restitution une nouvelle
lettre dans les mêmes formes lui a été
adressé le 10 septembre après à moi
après le premier envoi et cette fois
elle n'a pas été retirée elle été
renvoyée par la poste
j'aurais aussi vous faire part fait fait
qu' une telle procédure
à ma connaissance c'est à dire la
demande de restitution et le fait
d'engager une invalidation d'un
passeport n'a pas de précédent dans
notre histoire diplomatique en a
connaissance je suis pas renter au delà
d'une certaine date peut-être qu'on
pourrait on trouve des historiens pour
en trouver mais généralement les
détenteurs de passeports diplomatiques
s'en tiennent aux engagements qu'ils ont
souscrits par écrit enfin au bout de
quelques semaines et en l'absence de
toute autre information s'est posé la
question de la validation de ces
passeports diplomatiques
la procédure est donc été enclenchée au
vu de l'absence de restitution et à la
demande de la présidence de la
république qui nous a été transmise le
15 octobre et je redis que une situation
justifiant une invalidation de tels
documents n'avaient pas de précédent il
s'en est suivi a dialogue entre mes
services et ceux du ministère de
l'intérieur et le bureau des visas et
des passeports diplomatiques a notifié
par écrit le 8 novembre la demande
d'invalidation
il ya eu des échanges d'abord entre
service puis une démarche écrite le 8
novembre et nous avons demandé la laddh
l'invalidation des deux passeports
diplomatiques au ministère de
l'intérieur et cette demande a été re
confirmé le 19 décembre la
l'invalidation n'a pu immédiatement être
traduites concrètement dans les systèmes
d'information pour des raisons
techniques que je pourrais peut-être
développer tout à l'heure
essentiellement liée à l'incompatibilité
entre les bases de données du ministère
des affaires étrangères et celle du
ministère de l'intérieur en grande
partie due à au fait que la technologie
informatique du ministère des affaires
étrangères ne pouvait pas s'articuler
avec le dispositif informatique du
ministère de l'intérieur et donc il a
fallu que l'on fasse ce l'ensemble des
procédures par manuellement pour repérer
les numéros de passeport les
transmettent et cette articulation est
un des problèmes que j'ai constaté au
cours de cette période
par ailleurs étant donné les
déclarations contradictoires de monsieur
pénale à et constatant que certains
articles de presse sur l'utilisation de
ces passeports et constatant par
ailleurs certaines informations que dont
je disposais j'ai décidé le 28 décembre
soit quatre jours après les premières
informations de presse de saisir le
procureur de la perte de la république
en application de l'article 40 j'ai
demandé une couverte d'une information
sur les agissements de monsieur bénard
en tant qu il avait détenu est utilisé
des passeports diplomatiques
au delà du terme de sa mission enfin le
3 janvier à ma demande le bureau des
visas des passeports a saisi les avocats
de monsieur benalla d'une nouvelle
demande écrite de restitution des
passeports qui l'avait reconnu détenir
dans ses déclarations faites à la presse
etc passeport ont été remis le 9 janvier
par les avocats de monsieur ben à la
rose autorités judiciaires la police
judiciaire pour être clair ils sont
désormais entre les mains de l'autorité
judiciaire
je voudrais parler maintenant de
l'utilisation de passeports en
anticipation peut-être des questions que
vous pourriez me posez c'est dans ce
n'est que le 24 décembre dans un article
documenté paru dans le journal le monde
que j'ai appris l'utilisation faite de
ses passeports par monsieur benalla dans
ses déplacements à l'étranger il a
particulièrement dans le cas du tchad
jusqu'à là aucune information ne nous
était remonté et au demeurant
contrairement aux déclarations de
l'intéressé l'utilisation de passeports
diplomatiques nées par elle-même
en aucun cas signalés à chaque
utilisation aux services des ministères
niveau ambassade et nous avons obtenu
confirmation du passage au tchad de
monsieur benalla le 26 décembre
depuis lors des éléments concordants
nous laisse à penser que monsieur
benalla utiliser ces passeports
diplomatiques à de nombreuses reprises
après son licenciement et cela dès le
mois d'août
mais là il appartiendra à l'autorité
judiciaire que j'ai saisie de se
prononcer sur ce manquement à la
réglementation
enfin concernant la gestion des
passeports diplomatiques je vais redire
monsieur que je pense vous vous savez
déjà que le passeport diplomatique n'est
qu'un titre de voyage destiné à
simplifier les déplacements de leurs
titulaires en particulier aux contrôles
frontaliers
quand ils sont chargés d'une mission qui
justifie ces facilités en aucun cas la
détention d'un tel passeport ne confère
à son porteur une immunité quelconque
devant les juridictions
seuls les agents dotés d'un statut
diplomatique en raison des fonctions
qu'ils occupent de façon pérenne ou
ponctuelles peuvent se voir reconnaître
ce qu'on appelle l'immunité diplomatique
au titre des conventions de vienne mais
sûrement pas le passeport diplomatique
et donc les documents dont nous parlons
ne donne aucun droit simplement de la
facilité et de la courtoisie
pour autant et compte tenu des
difficultés que nous avons rencontrées
pour assurer les bonnes connexions entre
les fichiers du ministère de affaires
étrangères et ceux de l'intérieur devant
un tas qui n'étaient pas jusqu'à présent
qu'il s'était jamais présentée j'ai
demandé une inspection de l'inspection
de mon ministère
un rapport sur les procédures relatives
aux passeports diplomatiques et surtout
sur les fonctionnements des systèmes
d'information ce rapport n'a été
communiquée le 15 janvier et j'ai
l'intention d'appliquer toutes les
recommandations et je suis tout à fait
disposé évidemment à vous le transmettre
parce que c'est un document qui
permettra je pense c'est d'éviter les
certaine lenteur qui ont pu être
constatés parce que le cas était
totalement nouveau et qui est que par
ailleurs le dispositif informatique
n'était pas connectée et que par
ailleurs mais on ne reviendra sans doute
le dispositif informatique au sein du
ministère des affaires étrangères était
un peu anciens et qu'il apportera diapos
qu'il nécessitera d'apporter des
modifications des modernisations à ce
sujet mais surtout faire en sorte qu'il
y ait le lien entre les deux les deux
systèmes
mais cela n'a pas empêché la poursuite
d'une procédure à laquelle nous avons
veillé très attentivement pendant toute
la durée de cette affaire jusqu'à la
restitution du passeport et jusqu'à la
validation qui lui a d'ailleurs été
comptés rieur voilà ce que je peux dire
en commençant monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs rapporteur pour avant
d'ouvrir les discussions et de vous
fournir toutes les informations que vous
souhaiteriez avoir en complément je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre de ses
premières précisions
bien entendu nous souhaitons recevoir ce
rapport dont vous nous avez proposé la
communication et qui facilitera notre
réflexion sur les améliorations
apportées au fonctionnement de ce
système du passeport diplomatique
au fond nous nous demandons comment il
est possible après la tempête provoquée
par cette affaire benalla que une un
pilotage aussi peu ferme était mis en
oeuvre par ce que il ya une première
lettre recommandée non suivi d'effet il
y en a une deuxième n'est même pas à
retirer
il faut ensuite attendre le 8 novembre
pour que le ministère de l'intérieur
soit saisi et il semble qu'il y ait des
discussions entre les bureaux de la
place beauvau et du quai d'orsay assez
longue et finalement on constate
qu'aucune consigne est donnée à la
police de l'air et des frontières pour
que l'utilisation illégale d'un
passeport diplomatique à la sortie du
territoire soit empêcher autant
comprends très bien que citoyen français
qui franchit les contrôles de la police
de l'air et des frontières pour se
déplacer avec son passeport
comme tout un chacun ne puisse pas être
interceptées si il n'est pas poursuivi
par la justice par exemple autant il
paraît difficile de comprendre comment
les comment les les dispositions ont pu
ne pas être prises beaucoup plus tôt
pour empêcher à tout le moins à la
sortie du territoire
l'utilisation du passeport diplomatique
alors que la commission des lois avait
posé la question lors de ses auditions
de l'été et que par conséquent le sujet
n'était pas un sujet qui était resté
dans l'ombre c'est un sujet qui avait
été publiquement mis sur la table il
nous semble que dans ce type de cas il
est surprenant que on ait pu arriver à
ce résultat qu'il ait fallu attendre de
nouvelles informations de presse
révélant usage abusif du passeport pour
que des nouvelles initiatives soient
prises après les premières initiatives
qui l'avait été quelques mois plus tôt
et donc c'est la première question que
je souhaitais vous vous posez monsieur
le ministre c'est au fond est-ce que
vous êtes convaincu je suppose que vous
l'êtes mais nous le sommes moins que
toutes les diligences ont été fait pour
empêcher les âges de ce passeport qui
n'était pas restitué malgré votre montre
il y a eu deux phénomènes concomitants
il ya d'abord le fait que dès que le
licenciement de l'intéressé a été connue
j'ai demandé l'application de ce qu'il
avait lui-même signé
c'est à dire lorsqu'on a un passeport
diplomatique ou laurent et le passeport
diplomatique et pour lui était d'une
durée de cinq ans correspondait à sa
mission et à partir du moment où la
mission est interrompue il faut rendre
et j'ai engagé la procédure d'elle
quatre jours avant même licenciements
effectifs mais dès qu'on savait que le
licenciement est effectué c'est la
première démarche qu'il convient de
faire
considérant qu'ils avaient le mois
d'août que le délai d'un mois de réponse
man est un délai convenable j'ai réitéré
ma demande ensuite auprès de l'intéressé
qui n'a pas répondu
à partir de ce moment là nous sommes
rentrés dans la logique de la procédure
d'invalidation qui comme je le dis dans
mon propos introductif et n'a jamais eu
lieu
c'était la première fois c'est un
précédent que l'on décide d'annuler je
passe pas la question ce n'est pas
l'annulation du passeport c'est surtout
j'y reviendrai je pense l'annulation de
busage c'était c'est ça le sujet et à la
demande du cabinet du président de la
république et nous étions déjà dans
cette interrogation nous mêmes nous
avons engagé des discussions avec le
ministère de l'intérieur à partir de 15
e du 15 octobre pour parce que nous
avons reçu la lettre du
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république le 16 octobre partir du 16
octobre avec le ministère de l'intérieur
pour procéder à la validation du
passeport et nous nous avons il ya eu
des échanges internes qui était rendue
compliquée par le fait qu'il y a comme
je l'aï dit au début mauvaise
articulation entre les deux outils
informatiques nécessaires parce qu'il
suffit pas de dire on va invalider
il faut ensuite que la police de l'air
et des frontières là où se font les
contrôles soient informés du fait que ce
passeport soit invalides et donc il ya
eu les échanges internes qui ont abouti
le 8 novembre par une démarche de ma
part demandant là l'invalidation au
ministère de l'intérieur
ensuite il y a eu d'autres échanges
entre les différents services alors
j'hésite des échanges de même parce que
tu es un cas tout à fait nouveau qui
était posée comme n'y avait pas
d'interconnexion et en particulier pas
de lien direct technique entre l'outil
informatique du ministère des affaires
étrangères et l' agence nationale des
titres sécurisés
il a fallu agir autrement le ministre
l'intérieur nous a demandé des
informations supplémentaires que nous
avons mobilisé et il y à une deuxième
demande de d'invalidation le 19 décembre
19 décembre de notre part auprès
toujours auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur pour apporter des éléments
supplémentaires qu'ils savaient
sollicité et pour le faire valider ce
qui aboutit à une invalidation transmise
à l'ensemble des services concernés
c'est-à-dire à la fois des services
nationaux mais aussi de schengen
interpol et le service des passeports
volent des documents de des documents
volés au niveau international pour
aboutir à cette décision voilà le
premier sujet mais votre question en
appelle une autre
à partir du moment où
j'ai eu la conviction que l'intéressé
avait utilisé son passeport diplomatique
pour se rendre à l'étranger
j'ai estimé qu' il était dans une
situation illégale et j'ai saisi le
procureur j'ai eu cette conviction par
le voyage au tchad
c'est à dire le 24 décembre partir du 24
décembre
et c'est en concordants des informations
que j'ai eu la certitude que l'intéressé
avait dans son déplacement au tchad
utiliser son passeport diplomatique et
donc à partir de cette certitude là j'ai
saisi le procureur de la république
je remercie monsieur le ministre est
entendu que la saisine du procureur de
la république permette de poursuivre le
détenteur d'un passeport diplomatique
auquel ni n'a pas droit mais ne permet
pas dans l'espace qui précède la
restitution du passeport de faire échec
par une mesure de police à l'utilisation
de ce passeport nous a aimés pour autant
considéré illégal par l'autorité qui
utilise l'article 40 est précisément ce
qui manque dans
les diligences accomplies ces demandes
adressées soit pas vous-même soit pas la
présidence de la république au ministre
de l'intérieur de faire en sorte que ce
passeport soit interceptée s'il est
utilisé à la sortie du territoire
national et ça amène deuxième question
de ma part est ce que monsieur le
ministre puisque le directeur de cabinet
du président de la république nous a
révélé tout à l'heure qu'il y avait eu
depuis le 1er août 28 lisation ou plutôt
l'utilisation pour 20 voyages de ce
passeport et nous a renvoyés vers vous
en nous annonçant que vous soyez en
mesure de vous apporter des précisions
sur ce point
ce qui nous intéresse c'est de savoir si
ces vins utilisation ont été faites à
partir du territoire national ou
seulement à l'arrivée dans notre pays si
c'est à l'arrivée dans d'autres pays
nous ne pouvons pas reprocher aux
autorités de chad yens 2 d'avoir excepté
usage par un ressortissant français de
son propre passeport diplomatique
mais si c'est à la sortie du territoire
national la question est d'une tout
autre nature et donc comment avez vous
eu finalement la formation que 20
voyages avaient eu lieu
d'où vient cette information est ce que
c'est une information de police
est ce que c'est une information de
services de renseignement est ce que
c'est une information des postes
diplomatiques et qu'est ce qui permet
d'affirmer que dans ces 20 voyages il a
utilisé le passeport est est-ce que
c'est au départ ou à l'arrivée je n'ai
pas compétence en matière de police mais
au niveau de la question de l'arrivée je
peux vous donner des éléments
d'information que vous demandez le
chiffre d'une vingtaine de voyages que
vous évoquez me paraît tout à fait
plausible que l'ensemble de ses voyages
et été effectués sur les déplacements et
été effectuée par un passeport
diplomatique me paraît aussi par le blé
pain des deux passeports diplomatiques
me paraît aussi tout à fait plausible
parce que lorsque j'ai eu connaissance
des faits au tchad
j'ai demandé à notre poste de s'informer
auprès des autorités tchadiennes
si elle voulait bien nous faire savoir
si monsieur benalla avait utilisé son
passeport diplomatique lorsqu'il était
arrivé à djamena et les autorités
tchadiennes ont confirmé qu'ils avaient
utilisé le passeport diplomatique
par ailleurs j'ai interrogé un certain
nombre de postes qui me paraissaient
correspondre à des informations que je
pouvais lire ici ou là y compris
d'ailleurs des informations je sais pas
comment il s'appelle de monsieur
sur le mont qui lui-même se vantait que
monsieur banal à utiliser son passeport
diplomatique en indiquant d'ailleurs lui
même mais je crois que monsieur benalla
à fait la même chose ce qui est une
imaginaire fertile et à partir du moment
où monsieur benalla je prends l'exemple
de hoyo est une ville de du congo
brazzaville où il est allé voir le
président sasso et il a alors affiché
sur le manque il le dit dans un journal
je ne sais plus lequel je passe avec un
passeport diplomatique et donc tout le
monde sait où je suis or vous savez bien
que le passeport n'est pas un outil de
police ni de renseignements et le bruit
ou la rumeur ou des propos mêmes gens
très sérieux sur lesquels quand on a un
passeport diplomatique le ministre des
affaires étrangères sait où se trouvent
tous les titulaires du passeport
diplomatique on serait alors de l'état
ce serait la fin de l'état de droit et
donc ses propos sont dans l'imaginaire
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs dont
monsieur benalla en tout cas je reviens
mon argumentation
à partir du moment où je constate que là
il le fait savoir qu' il utilise son
passeport diplomatique
j'ai sollicité ascendant de postes pour
des lieux où il était censé s'être rendu
et j'ai eu de la part du tchad mais
aussi des autorités israéliennes
la confirmation que c'est bien le
passeport diplomatique qui a été utilisé
j'en déduis donc l'ensemble des voyages
qui a été effectué en dû l'être avec le
passeport diplomatique il ya une
vingtaine de voyages qui ont été faits
avec des dates qu'on connaît qu'on re
coup parce que lui même ou ses proches
en le se sont beaucoup répandu sur ce
sujet là il ya eu maroc le bas à 6 avant
de tout serré de deux pays dits fait
divers et variés j'en déduis que le
passeport diplomatique à utiliser a été
utilisé dans tous les cas de figure
merci de votre réponse monsieur le
ministre madame si vous voulez bien nous
allons revenir au renouvellement du
premier passeport diplomatique qui a été
délivré dans des conditions quelque peu
surprenante
tout d'abord la demande avait été
formulée le 23 mai 2018 le lendemain du
retour des quinze jours de suspension de
monsieur bénin et la demande a été
présentée alors même qu'il n'avait plus
vocation à se déplacer à l'étranger
puisque ses supérieurs lui avait retiré
la préparation et l'organisation des
déplacements officiels du président de
la république alors vous nous avez
indiqué tout à l'heure que vous n'étiez
pas vous en mesure au ministère des
affaires étrangères de connaître cet
élément je ne vous interrogerait pas sur
ce point
j'entends ce que ce que woods a tiqué
cependant quand même un élément sur
lequel vous pouvez nous répond je
pensais que le deuxième caractère
surprenant de cette demande et qu'elle
n'a pas été présentée par la voie
hiérarchique normal c'est à dire le
service du protocole de la présidence de
la république mais bien par monsieur b
dallas directement qui manifestement n'a
pas référer à ses supérieurs
comment se fait-il que vos services
traite cette demande qui finalement est
formulée par un chargé de mission de
l'elysée
sans que le service du protocole ne soit
en charge de cette demande et alors même
que l a été faite à l'insu de son
service puisqu'il était possible de me
supputer madame il s'agit à ce moment-là
du chef de cabinet adjoint du président
de la république
l'adjonction de quatre charges et
singulièrement de la préparation et de
l'organisation des voyages à l'étranger
il est temps en possession d'un
passeport dont il demande le
renouvellement et je ne suis pas informé
à ce moment-là personne n'était informé
dans mon administration du fait qu' il a
été suspendu d'une part et qu'il n'a
plus ses fonctions d'autre part et donc
classiquement lorsqu'il ya un
renouvellement puisque dans la première
la première attribution vérifie
l'ensemble des données concernant les
demandeurs y compris concernant les
services de l'elysée la validation par
le service du protocole on demande même
à ce moment là le contrat de travail
pour opter pour demander pour attribuer
le passeport à partir du moment où
c'était un renouvellement de liés à la
fonction avec des gens des services avec
lesquels mes propres services
travaillent régulièrement pour
l'organisation des voyages crois que le
service concerné n'y a pas vu ma dignité
et à engager la procédure
simplement ce que vous avez oublié c'est
que on envoyait copine l'information au
service du protocole
vous savez du progrès c'est une réaction
certainement très professionnel madame
jourdain
oui monsieur mais liste je vais
peut-être vous interroger sur quelque
chose qui apparaît eux évidents qui
finalement quelles sont les relations
entre la présidence de la république et
le ministère des affaires étrangères je
vais fonder cette interrogation sur les
faits suivants tout à l'heure monsieur
strzoda nous a dit qu'il avait appris il
ya quelques heures
très récemment que monsieur benalla
avait utilisé à une vingtaine de
reprises son passeport diplomatique pour
se rendre dans les différents endroits
que vous avez notamment évoqué ce qui
m'a étonné et m'a aussi beaucoup étonné
le fait que quand monsieur benalla est
arrivé au tchad pour être reçu par le
président de la république du tchad
quelques jours seulement avant l'arrivée
pour une visite d'état du brésil une
visite officielle du président de la
république eh bien il nous a été dit que
l'information il n'y avait pas
d'information sur ce sujet or je suppose
que les informations que vous avez
acquis auprès des postes diplomatiques
que vous avez cités j'imagine que vous
en ai fait part au service du président
de la république au directeur de cabinet
mais je suppose pas dû jouer
l'international et sur le rapporteur je
te répondrais oui
j'ai appris le déplacement de monsieur
benalla au tchad déplacement des 5 et 6
décembre
le 24 décembre mais que j'allais dire
comme tout le monde tourne pas comme
tout le monde j'ai amené le 24 décembre
compte qu'il n'ya pas de nom problème
d'information de riz et je pense que le
président wade a appris à peu près au
même compte tenu de quand même de la
qualité de nos services
oui de la qualité de nos ambassades
oui et du fait que monsieur benalla
quand même acquis une certaine notoriété
et que je suppose on s'intéresse
peut-être dans certains services à ceux
en activité je ne sais pas chauffer les
hypothèses vous paraît-il plausible
qu'ils soient reçus par le chef de
l'état sans que personne à l'ambassade
de france au chat ne se rende compte
n'en soit informée ne vous saisissent de
cette question
c'est une bonne question monsieur
réalisation permet de reposer je suis un
habitué du tchad et pour des gens diront
qu on pourrait en parler y est par
ailleurs et
et je sais que quand on connaît
l'aéroport de jamais n'at on imagine
bien que un avion privé de qualité qui
se posent à djamena ne passe jamais
inaperçu voilà des sources
aéroportuaires marque
j'ai interrogé le 26 décembre
notre ambassadeur sur ce sujet il m'a
fait savoir qu'il était informé de ce
déplacement et qu'il n'avait pas
considéré qu'il fallait en faire rapport
je lui ai fait savoir que c'était
regrettable il a reconnu que c'était une
erreur d'appréciation d'un événement
visuel qui avait été observé par tel ou
tel et il considérait que c'était la
relation entre le président deby est un
des lieux tandis que l'individu était
pas seul voilà ce que je peux vous dire
j'ai fait les observations nécessaire à
notre ambassade a donc vous considérez
comme moi même et comme certains de nos
collègues je pense qu'il n'est pas
normal qu'il n'y ait pas eu
d'informations sur ce fait au niveau
plus haut niveau de l'état
d'ailleurs je considère qu' il y a eu un
manque d'appréciation de la part notre
ambassadeur il s'en est expliqué depuis
il a reconnu son erreur
[Musique]
d'autre part vous nous avez fait vous a
fait état de toutes les diligences que
vous avez menées de manière à ce que le
pass pas qu'il soit le passeport soit
restituée mais vous rendez compte un
personnage qui se balade avec quatre
passeports dans deux diplomatique
peut-être d'autres on ne sait pas où on
s'évade ailleurs vous savez monsieur le
ministre du passeport nous allons vous
faire une confidence de regardons la
presse chaque patte à chaque soir
ne savons pas du tout d'ailleurs
peut-être que je me permets une
parenthèse que les informations sont
distillées encore très récemment de
manière à nourrir une sorte de prince et
parfois enfin une sorte de scénario dont
je ne sais pas quel est l'objet ni
qu'elle est là la visée à quoi ça sert
finalement bon mais pour terminer vous
nous avez dit que la copie de
l'attribution du passeport diplomatique
avait été envoyé au protocole de
l'elysée et il n'y a pas eu de réactions
parce que ce qui est bizarre voyez vous
c'est que monsieur ben là sans passer
comme dit madame jourda sans passer par
le service officiel du protocole de
l'elysée demandent individuellement donc
à passeport diplomatique le
renouvellement du passeport diplomatique
au moment même où il n'est plus chargé
nommé et donc je conclus et vous allez
me dire si je comprends bien monsieur le
ministre au moment où monsieur benalla
et des chargés de l'organisation des
voyages y compris à l'étranger puisqu'il
un passeport diplomatique le ministre
des affaires étrangères n'en est pas
informée
non mais trouvez vous trouvez normal à
partir du moment où la personne qui
s'occupe d'organiser les voyages à
l'étranger
pons de nommer des charges est connu et
surtout ne vous disent pas à monsieur le
rapporteur c'est le moi je n'ai pas à
m'immiscer dans l'organisation interne
de l'elysée mon interlocuteur principal
c'est le chef de cabinet du président de
la république et chargé lui-même
globalement de l'organisation des
déplacements et ils se faisaient entre
pas monsieur 62
deux déplacements et donc du coup
lorsqu'il demande le renouvellement d'un
passeport qu'il était tout à fait
légalement attribués personne n'y trouve
à redire ça arrive dans beaucoup de cas
et dans le monde obtenant beaucoup
d'administrations pour ceux qui ont un
passeport diplomatique il est donc
renouvelée et on le fait savoir le
notifie croyez le notifie sans protocole
si on pouvait réentendre ne va pas buzzé
vous savez c'est réentendre l'elysée
quand même c'est étrange que le service
du protocole recevant votre notification
comme quoi vous lui avait renouvelé son
passeport alors que le service du
protocole je suppose n'ignore pas qu'il
a été chargé mais vous ne savez pas
parce que s'ils services selon le
protocole fait en toute bonne foi si
ç'avait du protocole nine ignore le fait
que la personne a été déchargé de
l'organisation de ces volontaires qui
est un manque de circulation de
l'information ou qu'on a tellement voulu
que cette décharge de ses fonctions fût
et restât discrète que finalement ni le
ministre des affaires étrangères ni ses
services ni même le service du protocole
de l'elysée n'en avaient été informées
bon enfin et show fini h et plus
d'autres questions sauf peut être une
question sur le le passeport de service
mais l'avenir excellent intérieur je
dirais simplement que ça quand même été
un petit peu long entre le moment où
vous êtes rendu compte de toute façon
qu'il utilisait indûment le passeport
non mais vous dit finalement que c'est
avec ses quatre tentatives dont vous
avez saisi l'article 40 2,26 puisque
nous qui est qui qui parlons de
l'article 40 depuis déjà six mois
plusieurs mois nous voyons que l'article
40 prospère donc le 28 décembre
mais monsieur araignée luminet vous avez
tout d'un coup plus élancée pagny leamy
nation je veux vous connaissez ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça je sais je vous
connais depuis longtemps je fonctionnais
le début fait et je ne réagis
imaginez saisir le procureur sur la base
de l'article 46 je n'avais pas eu de
comité de fait et j'ai les faits à
partir du moment où notre ambassadeur
quatre prochains jours deux jours une
grande bâche sur ce point il s'est
rattrapé de son erreur me confirme que
les autorités tchadiennes on
vérifiez que monsieur pénale avait
utilisé le passeport diplomatique et g
dans le même temps je sais plus quel
toujours un ou deux jours avant parce
que je pousse fait peser des
investigations auprès des postes que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure en fonction de
ce que je voyais dans les journaux j'ai
la confirmation par notre de postes à
thé la ville que les autorités
israéliennes pouvait confirmer que
monsieur ben laden aussi utilisé le
passeport diplomatique à ce moment là je
m'estime font des fêtes de recourir à
l'article 48 ans avant parce qu'on ne
retourne pas on va pas l'article 40 même
si vous dites qu'ils prospèrent
moi je ne suis pas du genre à aller sur
l'article 46 ait pas d'effets nuit sur
derrière c'est tout monsieur le ministre
vous voulez vous remercier pour vos
réponses claires et si ce ministre enfin
je comprends bien vous vous êtes vous
vous estimez fondé à utiliser l'article
40 quand vous êtes certains que le
passeport diplomatique de monsieur biya
a été utilisé à l'étranger dans au moins
deux pays
c'est bien ça notre le centre de nos
investigations n'est pas le même
nous voudrions nous comprendre comment
il est possible que ce passeport soit
resté entre les mains de l'intéressé et
que des consignes n'est pas été donné à
la police de l'air et des frontières
pour le cas où il l'aurait utilisé en
france vous intéresser à la fraude
commise par monsieur b dallas ne nous
intéressons au fonctionnement de l'état
c'est normal nous avons deux examens qui
sont de nature
différents il est parti du bourget me
dit-on jet d'encre et 6 mai et ça c'est
ce sont des éléments de faits importants
le passeport diplomatique avez-vous dit
a été invalidée et effectivement comme
on est dans une forme de novation vous
l'avez expliqué vous utiliser ce terme
invalidée mais nous ne savons pas
exactement ce qu'il signifie qu'est ce
que ça veut dire matériellement une fois
qu'il est invalidée qu'est ce qui se
passe il est utilisé deuxième
deuxièmement à quelle date vous l'avez
peut-être dit tout à l'heure mais je
voudrais que vous leur disiez à quelle
date cette invalidation at-elle été
effective et quelles consignes ont été
données aux différents services
compétents à la suite de la validation
ce ne sont pas des consignes la question
de la validation
je les ai dit tout à l'heure c'est pas
de faire un autodafé du passeport c'est
de rendre son usage
impossible et j'ai indiqué que la
difficulté était de l'interconnexion
entre les bases de données y compris
pour permettre à la police de l'air et
des frontières de tel ou tel endroit de
faire en sorte que le clou lorsque le
passeport est présente et ça ça fasse le
bruit nécessaire pour que l'on se rende
compte que il n'est plus il n'est plus
valide c'est ça le sujet est bon pour
préciser ma question mais parce que
j'avais pas compris la question
non c'est peut-être fois qu'il est mal
de formuler mais vous comprenez je pense
que la police de l'air et des frontières
elle est encadrée par
des fonctionnaires qui ont une marge
d'appréciation et c'est pas simplement
comme l'ordinateur fait à son qu'une
alerte peut être donné je comprends très
bien que quand on introduit dans un
ordinateur un dispositif ça apporte une
assistance aux fonctionnaires de police
qui sont là parce que l'alerté donnée
par un mécanisme automatique mais il
existe certainement aussi des moyens
pour que l'état donne à ses services de
police des instructions dire si monsieur
benalla que vous reconnaîtrez peut-être
sa photo est parue dans le journal
devait utiliser un passeport
diplomatique retirer le lui est ce que
ceci à la suite de vos demandes a été
fait est-ce que l'invalidation du
passeport à cette conséquence dans le
fonctionnement de l'état
il ne peut plus voyager avec un
passeport diplomatique oui bien sûr
désormais non d'une part et à quelle
date cette invalidation at elle eu lieu
un peu 6 ou 27-28 descend donc donc il
est sur les fichiers d'interpol et sur
les fichiers schengen et je le dis dans
mon propos de départ et c'est là c'est
sous l'autorité de l'intérieur ma
responsabilité demander la validation ce
que vous allez faire ce que j'aime fed à
trois reprises à deux reprises à deux
reprises très bien je vous remercie de
ses réponses effet à deux reprises mais
c'est là qu'on s'est retrouvé confronté
ouf on précédent du fait qu'il n'y avait
jamais eu et n'a pas l'innovation de la
géomatique dans l'histoire et donc et
donc cela n'était pas armé pour faire
face à ce genre de livre et dans les
fonctionnalités et d'aider des outils
informatiques
oui mais il n'y avait pas un valide
assure donc pour retrouver le décès de
vous faire admettre qu'il n'ya pas des
ordinateurs pour faire fonctionner la
police n'a en rien changé par la justice
à ma connaissance
et oui mais ils le pouvaient faire
l'objet d'instructions pour utilisation
illégale d'un père biais d'un passeport
diplomatique d'instruction individuelle
bon nous en resterons là sur ce point
sauf si vous voulez apporter des
éléments complémentaires
est-ce que deux rapporteront ont
d'autres questions à soulever je n'en
avais pas je fais donner la parole tout
d'abord à monsieur phrase ça qui la
demandent merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre il se trouve que
comme sénateur des français de
l'étranger
je suis moi-même titulaires d'un
passeport diplomatique
et oui comme l'ensemble de mes collègues
sénateurs des français l'étranger et par
un heureux hasard j'ai un visa pour le
tchad
c'est un visa quand on a un passeport
diplomatique on l'obtient en fournissant
une note verbale peut-être première
question que j'ai à vous poser monsieur
le ministre
pourriez vous rappeler aux membres de la
commission denquête qui sont moins
habitués que nous à voyager avec un tel
document ce qu'est une autre verbal
comment elle se délivre par qui et pour
quoi faire puisque pour le tchad pour
voyager au tchad
on entre quand on a un passeport
diplomatique avec un visa la deuxième
chose pouvez vous donc me confirmer
qu'il faut une hotte verbal pour obtenir
un visa diplomatique sur un passeport
diplomatique
la troisième question monsieur benalla
at il sollicité une ou des notes
verbales auprès du bureau des visas et
passeport diplomatique de votre
ministère pour demander des visas
diplomatiques
sinon comment est il entré avec son
passeport diplomatique au tchad qui
n'est pas un pays avec exemption de visa
comme l'est le congo et dans le cas
contraire et comme l'a déclaré le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république à propos de la façon dont
monsieur benalla aurait obtenu un second
passeport de service pensez vous que
monsieur benalla aurait pu utiliser de
fausse note verbale en vue d'obtenir de
vrais visas diplomatiques
cinq ministres partie des questions qui
concernent les autorités tchadiennes
j'ai pas répondre à leur place moi je
n'ai pas été informé d'une note verbale
concernant monsieur benalla une soliste
et sollicitant à
[Musique]
auprès de l'ambassade du tchad à paris
un visa pour son déplacement au tchad
je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir toutes les
informations se je connais pas la
réglementation propre de chacun des pays
mais je ne suis pas sûr que pour un
court séjour il soit obligatoire d'avoir
un visa pour le club je ne suis pas
certain mais enfin c'est à vérifier en
tout cas à votre question sinon bien non
aux trois questions
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
grosdidier
merci monsieur le ministre effectivement
on reste effectivement tout seul tous
perplexe d'abord sur d'éléments auxquels
il a fallu quand on a procédé à
l'invalidation d'un passeport qui a été
réclamé dès l'été qui n'a pas été rendue
dès l'été puisqu'il a fait l'objet de
relance mais peut n'avoir pas tout
compris mais me semble qu'il ya une
contradiction entre ce que nous a dit le
ministre de l'intérieur qui a expliqué
une impossibilité de de validation pour
des raisons juridiques et et non pas
pour des raisons techniques
or vous vous nous expliquer que la
difficulté était d'ordre technique et
pas juridique alors sur les raisons
l'absence de raisons juridiques on
s'interroge puisque et penser que si
quelqu'un n'était plus en fonction pour
un passeport diplomatique
le fondement juridique était suffisant
et par ailleurs s'agit-il là que des
passeports diplomatiques au également du
passeport de service qui ôte et qui
aurait obtenu frauduleusement parce que
au moyen d'un faux et en paix d'une
fausse note
dudu du chef de cabinet donc
bon voilà ces questions restent ouvertes
en tout cas les réponses sont guère
satisfaisante en tout cas sur le plan du
fonctionnement des services de l'état
ensuite je voudrais savoir si alors
n'ait pas saisi le présent nous l'a
rappelé pavot interrogé sur l'éventuelle
diplomatie parallèle menée par monsieur
benalla en tout cas nous concerne le
lien qu'il peut encore avoir ou ne plus
avoir avec la présidence de la
république alors
at il eu parfois des retours
d'informations qu'il aurait pu connecter
au chat par exemple au pas au hasard sur
l'activité des russes au tchad et qui
aurait pu on aurait pu avoir
connaissance par monsieur benalla le
président de la république qui aurait
pas été transmis d'ailleurs par la cie
de l'afrique qui a connu je crois
quelques changements c'est ces derniers
temps quoi y at il toujours une relation
à votre connaissance ou ou plus aucune
alors mes chers collègues le ministre
s'il veut bien ne prend pas la parole
tout de suite et je vais proposer aux
autres collègues de poser leurs
questions
de sorte monsieur le ministre que nous
puissions accélérer un peu le cours de
nos travaux monsieur le comte
merci monsieur président moi j'avais la
même question et le même étonnement que
christopher frassa sur la question des
notes verbales qui pour moi sont
indispensables pour obtenir un visa sur
un passeport diplomatique lorsqu'une
pays ne pratique pas une exemption
c'est vrai que c'est facile d'avoir
cessé c'est très utile d'avoir un
passeport diplomatique parce que
beaucoup de pays pratiquent l'exemption
de visa mais lorsqu'il n'ya pas il y as
besoin à priori d'une note verbale c'est
en tout cas la procédure qu'on nous
explique pour pouvoir obtenir un visa et
les consulats angers en général des pays
potentiellement visités sont sensibles à
la délivrance de cette note verbale donc
on peut être étonné que des visas est
était éventuellement donner sans note
verbale s'il n'y a pas eu de notes
verbales ses administrés vous avez
répondu tout à l'heure la même question
mais il est temps d'inventer ces
problèmes ma réponse est non je n'ai pas
été soumis à une demande de notre verbal
sur le visa de monsieur ben alla pour le
tchad et je ne sais pas si ce serait à
vérifier parce que ça me faut un visage
au chat pour une durée très courte qu
elle avait d'ailleurs d'accord
je n'ai pas commis celui des autres
verbal vous ne pourrez pas nous apporter
tous les éléments de réponse à ce stade
mais je vous demande au nom de la
commission des lois dans le cadre d'un
pouvoir d'en quête de bien vouloir
interroger vos services et nous apporter
une réponse écrite d'ici la fin de la
semaine 6 à 10 ans problème un délai
trop court
je vous remercie de votre réponse madame
lherbier oui mais c'est le ministre a
répondu ah bon bah je réponds tout de
suite c'est le ministre en amont on ne
pouvait pas savoir que monsieur benalla
de par vos propos se servait de ce
passeport diplomatique
mais maintenant à postériori pouvons
pouvez vous avoir la preuve par
l'intermédiaire du ministère de
l'intérieur par là par l'intermédiaire
d'enregistrement je ne sais est-ce qu'on
peut avoir la preuve qu'ils se servaient
à l'as à la sortie de france avant de
rentrer dans les pays étrangers mais à
la sortie
peut-on a posteriori cherché à voir la
documentation voulue par des
enregistrements quelconque de ce le fait
qu'ils se soient qu'il est utilisé
ce passeport diplomatique à plusieurs
reprises selon selon lui et selon des
témoignages
madame jourda a demandé de les demander
une précision sur l'invalidation oui
monsieur le ministre
j'avoue ne pas avoir saisi l'ordre
monsieur le ministre madame jourdain
vous demande une précision sur les
réalisations du passeport diplomatique
j'avoue ne pas avoir très saisi
précisément en quoi consistait la
procédure d'invalidation vous avez mise
en oeuvre fin décembre 2018 alors que
vous nous avez expliqué avant qu'elle
n'existait pas donc je je souhaitais
savoir exactement de quoi il s'agissait
pas tout de suite monsieur le ministre
c'est aussi au fond le système
informatique ne permet pas d'empêcher le
passage d'un individu avec un passeport
diplomatique
qu'il détient illégalement et maintenant
interpol le fichier thèse tout le monde
a été prévenue pour empêcher ce passage
donc je voudrais comprendre enfin madame
jourda et moi même nous voudrions et
certainement les autres membres de la
commission après de comprendre s'il ya
là une contradiction où et comment elle
se résout alors maintenant je donne la
parole merci d'abord à madame dernier à
monsieur jacques bigot merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre on a
compris que monsieur benalla après son
licenciement fin juillet a très
rapidement trouver une activité
apparemment particulière d'intermédiaire
à l'international dans des affaires avec
des relations avec un homme d'affaires
dès lors comme nous l'a rappelé
d'ailleurs ministre l'intérieur monsieur
b n'avait aucune interdiction de sortie
du territoire ils pouvaient utiliser un
passeport ordinaire demander des visas
et circuler
l'utilisation de passeports
diplomatiques pourraient peut-être plus
facilité entrer mais ce que josé ader
qui paie pas de mention de la profession
sur le passeport diplomatique est ce que
le fait d'avoir un passeport
diplomatique et de faire usage comme il
l'a fait d'ailleurs pour vous demander
le renouvellement de 23 mai du spectacle
pratique d'une une fonction qui n'avait
plus à pully faciliter les relations
qu'il a nourri à l'international et dans
ce cas là et ça rejoint notre notre
mission est ce qu'on ne risquait pas de
mettre notre président de la république
en danger par le fait que lors de ses
anciens collaborateurs pouvait continuer
à faire croire qu'il était encore
collaborateur qui l'avait donc des
droits d'entrée particulière et des
relations particulières merci d'autres
questions cher collègue madame marie
pierre de la gontrie
merci président monsieur le ministre
vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure que
notre ambassadeur au tchad n'avait pas
cru
devoir vous faire remonter enfin faire
remonter au ministère l'information
concernant la visite les 5 et 6 décembre
d'alexandre benalla est-ce que de ce
fait vous avez interrogé d'autres
représentants dans d'autres pays qui
peut être de la même manière n'aurait
pas eu l'idée de faire remonter la
présence de monsieur benalla sur leur
territoire vous avez indiqué également
et je n'ai pas très bien compris que
vous aviez donc fait usage de l'article
40 le 28 décembre
ce que je ne cerne pas très bien c'est
pourquoi si tard sachant que la présence
de monsieur bénalia au tchad a été
rendue publique dès le 12 décembre alors
même que l'ambassadeur n'avait pas cru
devoir vous informer le 12 décembre par
la lettre du continent
puis le 24 par le monde
donc comment se fait-il qu après le 12
décembre il n'y ait pas eu davantage de
curiosité et enfin je n'ai moi non plus
pas très bien compris la sphère de
l'invalidation plus exactement à l'heure
où nous parlons je mets de côté le fait
qu'ils aient été rendues ces passeports
ont-ils été ou non invalide et mons
tournai mais merci mais avec quelles
implications
oui très bien merci merci cher collègue
monsieur kerrouche merci monsieur le
président monsieur ministre ça vient
d'être dit la révélation de la présence
de
monsieur alexandre men alao au tchad
c'est le 12 décembre dans la lettre du
continent qui est un organe relativement
lui pour ne pas dire très lu quand on
travaille dans les affaires étrangères
par ailleurs le 9 janvier un organe de
presse nous dit que madame la directrice
de la coopération internationale aurait
été informé par l'attaché de sécurité
intérieure de monsieur l'ambassadeur de
france au tchad
et donc ma question c'est pourquoi ça a
mis autant de temps pour arriver jusqu'à
vous et puis j'aimerais bien que j'ai
une certaine perplexité il faudrait que
vous vous m'éclairer sur l'élément
suivant
on nous a dit précédemment dans l'après
midi que il y avait 23 passeport
diplomatique actuellement qu'il n'était
pas qu'ils n'étaient pas retournés et si
j'ai bien compris si j'ai bien compris
donc vous avez pris des mesures
d'invalidation des passeports
diplomatiques de monsieur benalla avant
même que l'utilisation illégale de celle
de ceux ci pardon vous soins connu hélas
ma question elle est toute simple
pourquoi une mesure aussi exceptionnelle
inédite historique nous avait dit pour
quelqu'un qui depuis le début de la
faire nous est présenté comme un acteur
relativement périphérique dans les
fonctions qu'il avait pu avoir pourquoi
autant d'honneurs merci à
mais qu'est ce que vous n'avez pas
compris le cir ministre alors monsieur
que vous pouvez vous l'a précisé
je vais essayer de vous la reformuler
pour mieux pour mieux m'exprimer
a priori il y a déjà des passeports
diplomatiques qui ne sont pas retournées
c'est quelque chose qui existe
on nous l'a dit précédemment dans
l'après midi ça c'est le sept premiers
mois 23 ce qu'on nous a dit donc et vous
auriez demandé la procédure
d'invalidation des passeports
diplomatiques de monsieur benalla avant
même que l'utilisation illégale de
ceux-ci vous soit connu si j'ai bien
compris il va
vos propos et donc ma question est toute
simple
c'est pourquoi une mesure aussi inédite
historique vous avez dit pour quelqu'un
qui encore une fois est régulièrement
présenté comme un acteur périphérique
dans les fonctions qu'il occupait
précédemment
je veux remercier madame mercier merci
monsieur le président tous monsieur le
ministre on c'est une affaire très
confuse ça on a du mal à y voir clair
j'ai une question très simple
monsieur benhaddad et de nombreuses
missions je parle avant le 1er mai 2018
et il était chargé d'organiser les
voyages à l'étranger de monsieur le
président de la république
connaissiez vous monsieur benalla je ne
vous demande pas ce que vous en pensiez
connaissiez vous monsieur benalla
deuxièmement vous nous avez indiqué que
pour obtenir un passeport diplomatique
il fallait un contrat de travail donc
son passeport diplomatique qu'il avait
demandé le 23 mai et qu'il a eue le 24
mai 2018 pouvez vous nous dire pour
quelle durée il avait eu ce passeport
merci cher collègue monsieur françois
noël buffet ministre
je pose rigueur dans la question depuis
ce début d'après midi
dès lors que nous avons appris que
monsieur benalla avait utilisé au moins
vingt reprises
voilà notre édition spéciale se termine
mais vous pouvez suivre sur notre canal
24 24 la suite de l'audition de jean
yves le drian
le ministre des affaires étrangères qui
est interrogé sur les passeports
diplomatiques d'alexandre benalla
beaucoup de révélations parfois
explosives cet après-midi lors des
travaux de la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale que vous avez suivi le thème
traduit pour nous qu'avez vous retenu de
ces trois auditions cet après midi est
bien de cette audition de jean yves le
drian le ministre des affaires
étrangères et auditions qui est encore
en cours
on retiendra notamment et bien l'extrême
lenteur du processus de restitution et
d'invalidation des passeports
diplomatiques qu'il a été notifiée deux
fois par lettre recommandée puis le
processus de validation a été lui aussi
notifié deux fois tout cela a pris
plusieurs mois cela ces affirmations
sont à mettre également regard de ce
qu'a pu dire tout à l'heure le ministre
de l'intérieur
christophe castaner qui les a dit qu'il
y avait plein beaucoup de problèmes
techniques qui expliquait notamment que
le ministère de l'intérieur ne pouvait
pas invalidé des passeports
diplomatiques
on notera également que jean yves le
drian a dit tout à l'heure qu'il n'était
pas au courant des voyages alexandre
benalla notamment à propos de celui qui
a eu lieu au tchad début décembre le
ministre des affaires étrangères de la
appris at il dit que le 24 décembre par
voie de presse
sinon et bien on retiendra de ces
auditions les informations principales
et bien les bombes qui ont été lâchées
par le directeur de cabinet patrick
strzoda au début d'après midi
patrick strzoda qui a dit qu alexandre
benalla a utilisé une vingtaine de fois
ces passeports diplomatiques entre le
1er août et le 31 décembre
également il a rêvé qu'alexandre benalla
avait obtenu un passeport de service
auprès du ministère de l'intérieur en
utilisant du papier à en-tête de
l'elysée sans en avoir informé ses
responsables à l'elysée je le cite c'est
un monsieur qui a utilisé régulièrement
défaut pour obtenir des titres officiels
merci beaucoup au tam pour votre analyse
et je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
suivre sur notre canal 24 24 à la suite
de cette audition aux deux jean yves le
drian le ministre des affaires
étrangères qui donc entendu pour la
première fois par la commission
d'enquêté sénatoriale sur la sphère
benalla tous les temps forts de ces
auditions ce soir à 22h sur notre
antenne très bonne suite à des
programmes sur public sénat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]